so
so
okay
boys
foreign
good morning dear colleagues i will
start by announcing
the results of the votes for a few
minutes
the sitting is open
the results of the voting session of
yesterday tuesday 15th of february are
the following
on reports by veronica electric lenoir
on strengthening europe in the fight
against cancer
paragraph three part one adopted part
two adopted amendment 5 rejected
amendment 8 rejected
amendment 23 rejected paragraph 10
original text adopted amendment 6
rejected amendment 24 rejected
paragraph 12 part 1 and part 2 adopted
paragraph 14 part 1 and part 2 adopted
paragraph 15 amendments 25
part 1 and amendment 26 part 1 rejected
amendment 34 adopted
amendment 33 rejected amendment 25 part
two rejected amend amendment 26 part two
rejected amendment 35 adopted paragraph
15 part 1 and part 2 fall
amendment 27 part 1 and amendment 36
adopted amendment 27 part 2 and
amendment 38 adopted
amendment 32 rejected amendment 27 part
3 rejected paragraph 16
part 1 part 2 part 3 4
amendment 28 rejected amendment 9
rejected
paragraph 19 part 1 part 2 part 3 part 4
adopted paragraph 26 amendment 7 adopted
amendment 29 and amendment 10 rejected
paragraph 30 part 1 and part 2 adopted
paragraph 31 part 1 and part 2 adopted
amendment 30 rejected paragraph 35
original text adopted amendment 16
adopted amendments 31 and 37 adopted
paragraph 58 part 1 and part 2 adopted
amendment 11 rejected amendment 17
adopted
paragraph 63 original text adopted
paragraph 71 original text adopted
amendment 18 rejected paragraph 78 part
1 and part 2 adopted paragraph 83 part 1
and part 2 adopted
amendment 19 rejected amendment 12
rejected amendment 13 rejected amendment
20 adopted
paragraph 106 original text adopted
amendment 21 rejected
paragraph paragraph 126 part 1 and part
2 adopted
paragraph 136 adopted paragraph 138
original text adopted amendment 14
rejected paragraph 161
original text adopted amendments 15 1 2
3 4 and 22 rejected
recital y part 1 and part 2 adopted
recital a b original text adopted
recital ac
part 1 and part 2 adopted recital a d
part 1 and part 2 adopted
then report by gabriel martin bluefin
tuna
the commission proposal is amended
adopted referral back to committee
for inter-institutional negotiations
adopted report by valerie heyer on the
mobilization of the european
globalization adjustment fund adopted
report by dimitrios papademule is on the
european central bank's 2021 annual
report adopted
report by jeremy desell on animal
welfare adopted report by eliara evie on
the european ombudsman 2020 annual
report
adopted
report by morton peterson on the
european strategy for offshore renewable
energy adopted report by danutahner on
article 50 of the treaty on european
union adopted report by olivier schustel
on the sixth vats directive adopted
a couple of quick announcements uh in
relation to the decision by the econ
committee to enter
into uh inter-institutional negotiations
pursuant to rule 71 paragraph one
announced at the opening of the session
on monday 14th we have received no
request for a vote in parliament by
members or political groups reaching at
least the medium threshold the committee
may therefore start
negotiations
i will now move uh to uh the debate
dear colleagues as announced at the
beginning of this part session our
agenda of this week is dominated by the
situation
in ukraine
today we are starting our day with the
most pressing debate on eu-russia
relations european security and russians
military threat
against a ukraine amidst intense
international diplomatic exchanges to
de-escalate the situation
i am pleased to welcome the president of
the european council charles michel the
president of the european commission
ursula von der lion and the high
representative of the union for foreign
affairs and security policy joseph
borrel who are with us to discuss the
latest developments on the ground
in the wider context of european
security and eu-russia relations welcome
to the plenary
on behalf of the european parliament we
have repeatedly expressed solidarity
with the people of ukraine as they
continue to face the uncertainty of the
past weeks
and fear of russian military aggression
what we are witnessing here is also a
threat to peace in europe
i want to recall that in september last
year the european parliament adopted a
resolution that called
for containing russia's influence in the
eu and its eastern neighborhood and in
december last year we also adopted a
resolution where we criticized the
actions of the russian authorities and
underlined our preparedness to agree
swiftly on further joint action
including sanctions today
just after this debate we will vote on
granting 1.2 billion euros of macro
financial assistance to ukraine and i
would like to thank the european
commission for this timely proposal to
support ukraine's financial stability
and resilience in the current difficult
circumstances
also later today the conference of
presidents will discuss the declaration
on the situation
in ukraine
i would like to stress that
while we urge for a de-escalation of the
current tension between ukraine and
russia this parliament stands ready to
support
swift
forceful and concrete action in
coordination with other european
institutions
the union's unity and close cooperation
with our partners are key
for the european union to play a strong
role on the international stage and to
contribute to peace and security
we would be interested to know how
lessons learned from the current
situation will be reflected also in the
works on the future strategic compass
for the european union
finally i would like to thank you
president michelle president van der
lyon and high representative borel for
your engagement in the intense
consultation on identifying ways to
address the situation at the eu's
eastern borders and your efforts to
uphold fundamental principles of the
existing european security architecture
so without further delay
i would like to give the floor to the
president of the european council
charles michelle for your statement
madam president of the european
parliament madam prayer of the
commission
the high representative ladies and
gentlemen dear colleagues
this week is expected to be an important
geopolitical week for the european union
we will hold
our joint summit with the african union
some 80 delegations of african and
european leaders are arriving in
brussels to negotiate a strategic
partnership between our two continents
yet
the
extremely serious situation
in eastern europe
has strapped into all our agendas
and allow me to lay out the range of
actions
taken by the eu to deal with this crisis
in very close coordination with our
allies
and let me explain how the european
council will approach our future
decisions whether in the short or longer
term
ladies and gentlemen
russia
has undertaken an unprecedented military
stillation against ukraine
the russian authorities
have repeatedly said
they have no aggressive intentions
towards this sovereign country and this
despite already annexing parts of
ukrainian territory crimea in 2014
and constantly undermining ukraine's
sovereignty especially in eastern
ukraine
encircling a country
with
an extraordinary deployment of military
forces
never seen before
can only be seen
as aggressive
and strengthening behavior
this escalation
not only endangers the stability and
integrity of ukraine
it also threatens
peace
and security in europe
and the wolf-based international system
we
the eu
nato allies
member states
are working together at every level on a
daily basis
consulting politically and acting
together
we are working
at a level of intensity and quality that
we have not seen for years
our unity is stronger than ever
and we have adopted a strong
and clear strategy
in three areas
first
diplomacy
we have chosen to give every opportunity
to the diplomatic roots
european
and american leaders have undertaken
countless diplomatic initiatives and
missions
we have activated negotiating platforms
for dialogue with russia
such as nato
the oic or the normandy format
and i would like to commend olaf schultz
and emmanuel macron for the important
role
we have never stopped giving priority to
diplomatic channels
even when these efforts did not seem to
produce immediate tangible results
yet
in the last two days
russia has signaled that it may be open
to diplomacy and we urge russia
to take concrete and tangible steps
towards the escalation because this is
the condition for sincere political
dialogue we cannot eternally attempt
diplomacy on one side while the other
side is amassing troops
ladies and gentlemen in addition to our
diplomatic engagement we are working on
the second subject and that is
preparation of sanctions and restricted
were that to be necessary
so
the council will look at this with
clarity to come up with a position of
the 27 heads of state and government if
there were to be military aggression
against ukraine the cost for russia must
be severe the consequence must be
massive and we need to
make sure that these concepts that this
will that there would be consequences
for europeans as well and if the time
uh
were to come we will have to assume that
responsibility and i'd like to thank
everyone for the preparatory work that
has been carried out by the high
representative and the commission
the council and the member states and if
it were necessary and the time when the
time comes
the council will
make a statement and take the political
decisions necessary and we are in uh
close contact and coordination with our
partners and our allies
to conclude ladies and gentlemen there's
a third point that i believe is
essential
this point
would
have an impact directly on support to
ukraine and support to the ukrainian
people now this support must be as it
always has been politically uh political
to uphold the territorial uh integrity
and sovereignty of ukraine and we uh
confirm this uh
euro-atlantic aspiration of ukraine and
the european aspiration of ukraine
now through
this financial support we know that what
is happening already is bringing about a
daily significant
economic impact on ukraine and we would
like to commend the
commission's initiative to mobilize 1.2
billion in macro financial assistance
and i think we should go beyond that
with what our par with our partners
so that's like that's why i would like
to launch here initiative within um
close uh cooperation between ukraine and
the european union a conference of
donors to be able to support a robust
economic situation in ukraine um that
has been threatened by this uh
threat to the country to make sure that
we can um shore up uh support for the
ukraine now two messages i would like to
address at this point now the first
message i would like to
address to the ukrainian people in 2014
the free and proud uh
ukrainian people took to maiden and
there were sacrifices that were made
and
they made the choice for freedom for
democracy and for liberal democracy for
the rule of law the european union
supported uh made this choice to support
this a free and sovereign choice of the
ukrainian people and i would like to
reiterate
the fact that the european union will
not
allow the ukrainian people to be left
without support now i would like with
the second message to address russia and
its leaders the choice today is a choice
between war
and the tragic sacrifices that would go
along with that war or
with a
the courage of a political engagement
the courage of a diplomatic negotiation
very clearly the european union would be
in favor of diplomacy and
negotiation and we will also show
our
stringency if another choice were to be
made by russia and aim for a sustainable
solution to uphold
the security mutual and reciprocal
stability and security and this is why
the russian uh leaders owe this to the
russian people now in just a few hours a
time the 27 member states and uh will be
will meet in brussels for the african
african union eu summit and i am sure
that we will be resolute in expressing
our solidarity with the ukrainian people
thank you
thank you very much president michelle i
give the floor now to the president of
the european commission ursula van der
line for her statement
documents in case that they have to rush
away from home
others have stockpiled food cans to
prepare for the worst
some have even set up shelters in their
basements
these are not stories from the 1940s
this is europe in 2022
and this is happening
because of deliberate policy of the of
the russian leadership
ukraine is a sovereign
country it is making its own choices
about its own future
but the kremlin doesn't like this and so
it threatens war
and this is the essence
of the current escalation this is some
something we simply cannot accept
i think diplomacy has not yet spoken its
last words
and we saw signs of hope yesterday
but now deeds have to follow those words
in the last seven years
ukraine has suffered from the kremlin's
constant aggression
but despite that
heavy burden they have ukraine has come
such a long way
it has taken important steps to fight
corruption it has rebuilt its
infrastructure it has created new jobs
for its talented youth
and our union has accompanied them
putting together the largest support
package in our history
of course the people of ukraine know
that their democracy still has some
flaws and issues to deal with it
but ukraine today
is a sovereign
more free
more strong country than in 2014
and this is precisely why the kremlin is
threatening it again
we stand firm with ukraine
the idea that the kremlin should decide
what ukrainians can or cannot desire we
simply cannot accept and the idea of
spheres of influence
are ghosts of the last century
this crisis is about ukraine yes but it
is also about much much more
it is also about what it means to be a
sovereign independent and free country
in the 21st century
it is about everyone's right to live
free from fear
and it's about every country's right to
determine its own future and this is the
message that our union has to send to
the kremlin
like everyone in this room i truly hope
that the kremlin will decide not
to unleash further violence in europe
yesterday russia was certainly sending
conflicting signals on the one hand
authorities announce russian true
pullbacks
on the other hand the duma votes for the
formal recognition of donetsk and
luhansk as independent republics
but i still strongly believe in
diplomacy
it is good to hear yesterday's
commitment to the minsk agreement
president macron and chancellor schultz
have traveled to kiev and moscow
several others
are also speaking to both sides
i'm constantly exchanging
with all of them as well as president
biden prime minister trudeau prime
minister johnson i must really say the
transatlantic community has for a long
time not been so united
let me just mention one recent episode
earlier this month
russian foreign minister lavrov
wrote 36 letters to each and every
member state of the european union and
nato ally with a series of demands
he received two letters in response
one from joseph burrell
on the behalf of the european union
and one from jens stoltenberg
on behalf of nato
the european union and its transatlantic
partners are united in this crisis
and our call to russia is crystal clear
do not choose war
a path of cooperation between russia and
us is still possible
but let's stay vigilant
despite yesterday's news
nato has not yet seen signs of any
russian troop reduction
and should the kremlin choose violence
against ukraine our response
will be strong and united
the european commission and the eas
working closely have been working
closely with all member states to
prepare a robust and comprehensive
package
of potential sanctions
and we have worked in very close
coordination with our friends from the
united kingdom the united states and
canada and let me say in that in these
weeks we have built a unity of purpose
that is truly remarkable both within the
european union and with our partners
in case of a russian aggression
europe's reaction will be swift and
robust
and we're not just talking about
freezing assets and banning travel for
russian individuals
russia's strategic interest is to
diversify its economy its one-sided
economy and to close its current gaps
but for this
they need technologies in which we have
a global leadership
high-tech components of which russia is
almost entirely dependent on us
so our sanctions can bite very hard
and the kremlin knows this as well
and on another topic we are also ready
in case that the russian leadership
decides to weaponize the energy issue
you know we see at a time of high demand
that gas problem is restricting its gas
supplies to europe we see a 10 years low
in storage by gas chrome
we see no sales on the market spot
market this is a strange behavior for a
company that in times of skyrocketing
demand and prices they are not trying to
maximize their profits
and this behavior has already damaged
russia's credibility as a reliable
energy supplier
we are since weeks and talks with a
number of countries that are ready to
step up their exports of liquefied
natural gas to the european union
and this resulted now in january in
record deliveries of lng gas more than
120 vessels that is the equivalent of 10
10 billion cubic meters of lng
and on top we've done our homework since
the annexation of crimea we have
increased the number of lng terminals in
the european union
we have reinforced our pan-european
pipeline and electricity interconnector
network
and the good part in this story is that
these investments in infrastructure we
have done
will in future be the backbone for the
possibility to supply with green
hydrogen so they are future proof
and now we have during the last weeks
looked into all possible disruption
scenarios in case russia decides to
partially or completely disrupt gas
supplies to the european union
and i can say today that our models show
with all the measures we have taken
that we are now on the safe side for
this winter
on top of this
we have also developed with a number of
member states a new set of emergency
measures
which we could trigger in case of
complete disruptions
but one of the main lessons we have
already learned from this crisis
honorable members is
that we must diversify our energy
sources and we must get rid of the
dependency of russian gas we must
heavily invest in renewables
our alternative are renewables because
though renewables are clean and good for
the climate but they are also homegrown
and good for our independence that's
where our future lies
honorable members this is a crisis that
has been created by moscow
we have not chosen confrontation
we are hoping for the best
but we are prepared for the worst
we now have two distinct futures ahead
of us
in one
the kremlin decides to wage war against
ukraine
with massive human costs something we
thought we had left behind
after the tragedies of the 20th century
moscow's relation with us would be
severely damaged tough sanctions would
kick in with dire consequences on the
russian economy and its prospect of
modernization
but another future is possible
a future in which russia and europe
cooperate on their share interests
a future where free countries work
together in peace
a future of prosperity
built on the respect of the fundamental
principles
that are enshrined in the un charter
and in the european security
architecture since the helsinki final
act
this is my aspiration and i'm sure
the russian people
share this aspiration too
it's now up to the kremlin to decide
but whatever path they decide to take
we will stand our ground
europe will be united
on the side of ukraine
on the side of peace
and on the side of europe's people long
live europe thank you
thank you
very much
president van der lyon i invite now high
representative joseph porrell to take
the floor
president of the european parliament
president of the european council
and president of the european commission
honorable members
if we take a look at what is happening
in ukraine
this i think is going to mark determine
the future of humanity
i think everybody all human beings must
be concerned about what is happening
there because if once again it's the law
of the strongest and if we see that a
country can threaten another
and
invade it threaten it
in territorial terms we're taking a step
back in our history the major success in
europe is that we have turned our backs
on war as a way to resolve conflicts and
i think
this is the reason why we have to stand
side by side with ukraine and to prevent
a war on our borders and all of this
forms a fundamental part of what we call
the common
defense and security policy and it is a
great honor for me to try and spell this
out for you today
we have the presence in the
chamber today in the hemi cycle of the
leaders of all the institutions we have
the president of the european council
and that we have the president of the
european commission the european
parliament
and i am here
uh on the behalf of the eas
as the leader of the actions of security
and defense in the european union and we
are here together to show our unity
against the russian threat of invasion
of the ukraine of ukraine
and this unity in solidarity i think has
come to the fall over the past few days
so we have to take a look at how we can
have positive consequences
of this crisis there has been a coming
together a common position of the member
states and all europeans have
responded positively
to come up with a response
we call this sanctions or deterrent
measures and all of this pursuant to the
treaty
we're
looking at sanctions which would have to
be adopted by the council following a
proposal by the high representative
and these are going to be drafted of
course are being drafted together with
the
uh help and support of the european
commission
in order to take a look at
its their costs that what these are
actually going to mean and obviously
under the
european council and obviously these
will come into play if russia invades
ukraine but perhaps i can insist on
a fundamental aspect of our union
which i think is the most positive
consequence to come out of this crisis
this is a crisis that has been based on
a threat to the territorial integrity of
a state
it is a crisis that has come about and
affects
the whole security structure in europe
and this is something that cannot be
questioned at all through threats of
this kind and it's a crisis that affects
the right of every sovereign state to
freely choose its own security structure
and its own international relations
into english
which has been the role of european
diplomacy
in these events
it has been said that europe was missing
in action
we have heard
that the european is missing in actions
and things are happening without
our presence without a participation
led by united states who are negotiating
over our head
i think that we have to respond to this
criticism
which seems at all unfunded by several
reasons
first because the member states of the
union have consistently debating the
issue of security in europe and ukraine
and we have achieved a remarkable unity
because every member states france and
germany have taken a number of political
initiative
to promote a peaceful settlement of the
crisis
and these initiatives have been carried
in coherence
with the positions of the union and in
conditions of great transparency
and third
because russia
deliberately tried to ignore the
existence of the european union
by sending letters only to the united
states and nato in december
considering that we are completely
relevant and has nothing to say about
the security issues in europe
for moscow the security in europe is
being defined in washington
later
when they will notice that
despite this dismissive attitude
nothing was going on minister lavrov
finally decided to send a letter to the
27 member states
that he had enough until now
why such a new turn on the russian
position
for two reasons
first
because they realized that the european
front was not crack
and the atlantic solidarity was very
strong
so he tried to maneuver
which was to send letters to the 27
member states hoping to have 27
different answers
but in this case
mr lavrov didn't succeed
because we sent him
a single letter
saving him the time to lead to read 27
letters all of them equal
just one
one letter representing the position of
the european union on behalf of the 27
member states
and this is a good example of how do we
europeans we can work together
and together with our allies with the us
and other like-minded countries with
which we have had a continuous and very
much positive coordination
so we have been present participating
on the negotiations if we can call them
negotiations at least conversations
until now
so what we can envisage next
well
we don't know
nobody knows they are encouraging signs
but also
very much rewarded some events
like devoting to douma asking putin
to recognize
the independency of the two let's say
republic and the donbas
we don't know what putin is going to do
but what is clear that we have to
continue offering both things at the
same time
the will to negotiate
be ready to participate in talks because
yes russia has also security concerns
that has to be taken into consideration
and on the other hand
to prepare
our capacity to respond
our dissuasion tools
sanctions as a panel of the commission
and the president of the council has
been referring to
on that we have been working and on that
we are ready to act
but
most of all we are ready to continue
negotiations talk in order to look for a
diplomatic solution to the worst crisis
that europe is living since the end of
the cold war
and i repeat again this crisis not only
affects ukrainians not only the
europeans
it's affect the direction of humankind
thank you very much
thank you
very much to the high representative
we will now do a round of
starting with the political groups and
not many colleagues who will take the
floor on this important debate starting
with the chair of the european people's
party group manfred weber
president mitzola president frondeline
president michelle vice president
it's good that you're all here
it's important that as europeans
at this time
stand together and discuss
it's about a basic promise
the basic promise of the european union
of peace
the fear of the ukrainians
something we can't
imagine the worries then it's not just
about ukraine it's about us
securing peace the first question we
have to put
is what is this conflict conflict all
all about many
say it's about the eastern expansion of
nato security interests i don't believe
that in the 80s
people went on the streets in gdansk for
peace and democracy at the end end of
the 80s in dresden in the baltic
countries in budapest
and the fall of the iron curtain the
fall of communism
and then maidan in kiev when people
fought for freedom of democracy and also
died and now some years ago
in minsk
in belarus
when people
went onto the streets for these ideas
the idea of peace wins
step by step it moves ahead
i was in maidan myself in 2014 i spoke
with young people there
one thing must be clear for us europeans
we are on the side of people who are for
peace and democracy
it's another moment perhaps where it's
about our fundamental values and we have
we will defend them whatever it takes
colleagues
is the greatest threat
that's the biggest threat for putin is a
free democratic ukraine the second
question we must answer
is
what is our task
how can we ensure peace
putin only understands the language of
power and it means
we need
a clear bill we can give him the costs
are high
for my political party the epp i can
ensure i can assure that
naught seems to won't go ahead if
there's violence um the exclusion for of
russian banks from the european from the
international finance financial system
is necessary and
the limitations of
deliveries of high technology announced
by the commission are on the list
there's a electoral campaign
uh in france because of north stream two
it's difficult in germany so we're not
strong in these issues we should be
stronger
and the bill that we present
can be put in clear terms any
insecurity motivates perfume to go down
his road the second third question we
must ask is
how
can we talk to put in other
possibilities
for compromise
dialogue is important
talks are important
sovereignty of states can't be touched
there are no spheres of influence where
putin can decide and war is no means
for
politics in today's
uh europe so
um the
unconstitutional declaration annexation
of crimea is against international law
the fourth question
um
hasn't he achieved a lot uh putin he has
a free hand in bularus
lukashenko is a puppet of the kremlin
and they have joint military exercises
in the duma
there are demands
to
recognize east ukraine as a state to
reinforce the divide
of ukraine that is a cause for further
sanctions
and some weeks ago here in the european
parliament we had you alexei navalny we
awarded him the sucker off price now we
hear that uh he faces 15 more years in
prison without any illegal basis or any
due process
the putin is taking the trying to take
the idea of freedom away from the
opposition in russia and that's a
further reason to discuss sanctions
against russia
that's
that's
also covered by the saber rattling and
the threats we face the fifth question
is is our own role as european union
let's be honest
we are not sufficiently prepared
for this storm in world politics we face
we're not prepared enough in geneva
there's no european politician on the
table when we talk about the european
security architecture
and decisions are made there germany
france are trying to coordinate but it
could
work better
we know that in sanctions
the question is in the room if perhaps
victor orban
will break ranks and have different
positions
i must also criticize the fact that in
this historical phase no
um
european states are in a position to
send a
strong signal that we're on the side of
ukraine no um signal from the heads of
state and government
colleagues
the development is a wake-up call in
security and policy foreign policy we
must develop our
force our power
and
have a cyber uh warfare brigade to
defend critical infrastructure we need a
foreign minister who is able to speak
for the entire european union with a
strong voice
uh i wake up every morning early
and ask myself can it be the case um
that we're talking about war i think
that's the same for many europeans
there's somebody in moscow who is
prepared uh to use war he's
shown this many times
we'll wake up in a new european reality
and a new european union and now we must
prepare for that
peace and
democracy are
the promises of the european union for
and 44 million
ukrainians expect that and i think we in
the european parliament stand behind him
thank you
thank you and now on behalf of the smd
group
i invite iracia garcia perez to take the
flaw
thank you
my president
over eight years have gone by since the
revolution of dignity in the maidan
square and since the ukrainian people
have started their fight in order to
move forward to the project of
rights and democracy i.e and we in the
european union have been their most
faithful partner when it comes to
supporting their reforms and to
defending sovereignty the sovereignty
and in territorial integrity of ukraine
and today the european parliament is
repeating its commitment to ukraine the
challenge that russia poses to all
europeans
basically gives us an opportunity to
strengthen our solidarity and
determination and also to defend our
interests and those of our continent as
a whole but we should not forget that in
order to
in order to
put a halt to putin's imperialist
tendencies then ukraine and the european
union are also going to have to
fulfill their own obligations we're
going to have to continue
all efforts in all diplomatic forum in
order to put an end to the conflict in
uh uh ukraine the normandy format uh the
um
uh tripartite
format as well and the european union
has to be present in these negotiations
because as president mr burrell has said
we can't sit on the sidelines there's a
neutral spectator when it comes to those
matters that affect our security no
region around the world has
a system of security that is as fair as
ours all the values that are set out in
the
paris charter or in the helsinki final
act all of these instruments have been
signed by russia and they're the only
ones that can guarantee security in
europe
sovereignty and the territorial
integrity of states the inviolability of
borders and the right to for a state to
choose their own allies and peaceful
resolution of disputes
are achievements that cannot be denied
and obviously this can only be a reality
our life in europe can only be reality
if we have security and none of us i
don't think can deny
the fact uh this fact and we will not
allow putin and his blackmail uh to
bring europe to its knees
we are looking at our
ability and capacity to respond in the
face of the threats we're looking at
medium-term reserves and purchases of
gas and we're still leading in the
structure the building of a new energy
infrastructure based on renewable
energies and a fairer distribution of
energy it is the time for
diplomacy but also for deterrence any
kind of aggression towards ukraine will
have considerable consequences for
russia
and
you could always try and prevent it
until the moment that war starts so we
we have the basis of our european
project and we have all the achievements
that we've managed to bring about the
freedom and democracy that have
characterized the lives of millions of
human beings and president zielinski is
also going to have to continue with his
commitments on the path to democracy
fight corruption strengthen reform the
judiciary because these are the best
arms and weapons against russia
what russia fears is that our social
model and a democracy
make find their way to the red square in
moscow all of us i think are fully aware
of the fact that trying to convince by
force
you can't convince that way and putin is
not going to be able to convince anybody
to convince you have to persuade
somebody and you have to persuade
somebody
that they are missing something i the
right to do something and they are right
in doing something so there isn't much
time left ukraine has to
realize that the social democratic
family is that behind them those people
who lost their lives there on maidan
square and in donbass this is our
commitment we have to show that
commitment with our neighbors
and bring about prosperity and democracy
thank you ms garcia perez and now on
behalf of the renew group stephan sajuna
thank you madam president
president of the council
commission president colleagues
first of all
on behalf of my group renew i'd like to
express
the deep solidarity with the ukrainian
people for the third time
the ukrainian people
are facing ex
unacceptable external pressure the
resilience and the calm of ukrainian
citizens deserve admiration
the courage of these people which have
paid with
blood uh for its european choice the
european parliament is always on the
side of ukrainians to defend their
choices which are sovereign
their territorial integrity and their
independence
i'd like to welcome the work of
president zielinski and his government
which ignores um propagations and
continue with reforms
we're not responsible for the situation
but we have a moral duty to act
firstly
we have to act on the side of the
ukrainians we must strongly condemn
the attempts of destabilization by the
russian government we must point out to
russia that has international
obligations under the osce and the
respect of international law
in particular in maritime law which is
not respected at the moment we call on
the commission
to make a strong uh sign to
all towards the
european ukrainian people and open up to
the single market and go beyond the
association agreement secondly
we must act
for maintaining peace
our union is
born from the promise of peace and it
must remain our sole compass that's what
european citizens ask for that is what
for the ukrainian citizens want
also it is the majority opinion
of the russian population which despite
ongoing propaganda is against military
intervention we need to have that in
mind
the french
german and polish initiatives which have
been welcomed
are
an open
means that we can reopen uh channels of
dialogue which should be welcomed in
this hemi cycle thirdly we must act to
be uh prepare for all eventualities i'd
like to thank the president of the
council the president of the commission
for the two speeches
our strong attachment to peace doesn't
mean that we're naive
all the institutions must work
on the collective response of the
european union what will be the scenario
i call on the commission and the council
to prepare sanctions
uh of an on an unprecedented scale and
aid for countries which will be most
affected by such decisions
we must be prepared to act immediately
we must show this time that our force
our economic power
is at the
services of its geo political interests
finally
we must act
and ensure long term the security of our
continent
let's be clear
it's the attraction of our model which
is a problem for putin
it's the european aspiration of ukraine
which is seen as a threat at the moment
when i listen to certain europeans i
think that we are the
uh not realize what we are we are a for
economic power social power
power but also which is attractive also
a democratic power
um we we have unity uh through this
conflict
national elections uh or attempts at
destabilization or certain political um
uh forces in the uh
kremlin shouldn't
imperil our unity for ukraine for our
values and also for our co-citizens
thank you very much
merci
journal
on behalf of the green group i now give
the flow to scockeler
thank you
ukraine is under threat
a country that just as any other country
wants to decide on its own future
but is bullied by its big neighbor
but this is not just a threat to ukraine
it's also an attack on the basic idea of
how states relate to each other it's a
threat to international rules and to
european security
and it saddens me profoundly that we
have to debate this dangerous
development in our eastern neighborhood
today
this european parliament was born out of
the devastating experience of war and
violence
the eu was built as a peace project and
a model of democratic cooperation
president putin's nationalist and
imperial course of action and
suppression runs contrary to the mere
idea
of our common union
putin's actions therefore challenge us
as europeans
and we as members of this parliament
carry a historic responsibility to stand
up
and clearly condemn russia's threat of
aggression
as eu
as its parliament we stand united
against the russian threat and in full
support with ukraine
the people of ukraine have our support
for choosing their own path
for living in peace and for undertaking
reforms that will transform their
country for the better
we need to be prepared for sanctions
against individuals entities and sectors
in russia i am talking for example about
freezing assets about entry bans and yes
i am also talking about nordstrom 2.
this pipeline must be part of our common
sanction regime
and yes sanctions have repercussions
also for ourselves
but we must act in phase of an
aggression
as union we need to reduce our
dependencies on russia especially when
it comes to energy we have the
technologies to do so and we have ample
supplies of sun and wind
what energy we use is a geostrategic
decision and we need to make the right
one
let's not forget that the ukrainian
people have suffered greatly already
because of the russian aggression going
on for years
in eastern ukraine
almost 15 000 people have died more than
a million ukrainians had to flee their
homes
conflicts can only be solved by
diplomatic means
russia must withdraw its troops and end
the threat of invasion
it must return to the table of frank and
peaceful negotiations
negotiations that must be based on
international law
mutual respect and a common vision for
peace on our common european continent
this is a key moment for international
peace stability and security
now is our time to show through words
and through actions that we stand unite
not united as one and that the people of
ukraine can count of us thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much miss keller i give
the flow now to marco zanni on behalf of
the id group
thank you president
president fonda line
president michel
i believe that today the message from
the european union
should be sent to the ukrainian people
and that message should be of solidarity
we shouldn't leave any openness to
ambiguity ambiguity that
often in the
recent past
have
has emerged from the european uh
institutions and i listened very
carefully to what was stated by the
president van der lyon and by president
michel as well as from the high
representative
burrell
i do not agree with the optimism that is
shown here
in under these uh
current circumstances
current circumstances i think there is
much ambiguity that remains in terms of
what the uh putin regime places on our
borders
we must be resolute and
express a message to ukraine
that europe is prepared to do anything
and everything to uphold its
sovereignty and territorial uh integrity
no transgressions here and we also need
to recognize the mistakes that we have
made and understand why there is has
been this ambiguity why europe hasn't
been able to send out a united and
concrete message
in the face of this and clearly
clearly there have been mistakes we've
discussed for example the dependency
that exists that
our countries have vis-a-vis the russian
regime this is nothing new these are
things that we have known for a very
long time and we have done nothing to
reduce that dependency now ambiguity is
a problem
because we understand that the
dynamics of dictatorships are difficult
for us to understand those for those of
us that live in free con countries but
clearly we can
fully understand that our weaknesses and
our ambiguity
give a space to threats and give space
to powers that would like to bring war
to our within our borders now we can
understand
that uh from
some 20 years now since the last war
that we experienced here in europe in
the kosovo and in the balkans
we can uh we can feel the
winds of war are on our borders and this
is uh this 20 years without war has been
a success of the west so what clearly we
need to avoid at this time is a war or
an escalation that would lead to
military conflict no one wants this and
no one is in a position to
deal with this but we must
have the courage to correct the mistakes
that we have made and that this
ambiguity is quite clear even though we
often
just sweep it under the carpet we know
of course that putin is the
previous
head of
important structure within the continent
continent of europe so we need to work
for peaceful
resolution without transgressing our
principles and find a way to be able to
leave the space such that we can show
that the west is united that europe is
prepared to move beyond its ambiguity
and state of course our
message of competence within the
framework of nato and with our allies
and that is within nato that we must
resolve this situation otherwise our
ambiguity will continue to be a weakness
and we will never be able to be a
positive player in resolution
of conflict and in the protection of the
freedoms that we must be so proud to
protect thank you i give the floor now
on behalf of the ecr group to mr legutko
thank you uh madame
president ladies and gentlemen
when in 2008 uh the russian army
invaded georgia poland's president
that kaczynski gathered political
leaders from ukraine
estonia latvia and lithuania in
pvc and at the public meeting he said
these
memorable words
today it is georgia
tomorrow ukraine then the baltic states
and in the future maybe poland
well unfortunately these words are not
only memorable
but they sound prophetic too
but
there is a discrepancy between east
european and west european
political sensibilities
for most east europeans russian
imperialism
is a fact
that has determined
and continues to determine their very
existence
for the west europeans it is simply news
in the media some sometimes
sensational and exciting but generally
it is a rather tedious story in a fire
of land presumably made up but by some
political
fantasists
to make the matter worse
russia has become an object
of deep attraction for many europeans
and additionally an engaging partner in
power politics
also in economic relations not to
mention the notorious uh not stream one
and not stream two
and the fact that uh former chancellors
of germany and austria
former prime ministers of france and
finland
have been working for russian businesses
were employed by russian businesses is
meaningful
these gentlemen
and many others too
also ladies let me add are not mavericks
but they represent what is typical of a
large segment
of european political establishment
to call a spade a spade
europe is a weak link
in the line of defense against russian
imperialism
no wonder that putin likes to humiliate
the european politicians and has been
quite successful in this
those politicians desire to accommodate
russia
and are keen on conducting business as
usual with her
and this is the reason why the de facto
accepted the annexation of the crimea
well recent signals from europe and
also from outside
europe have been rather mixed but there
is a lot of
reassuring talk
about the hardening of the european
position vis-a-vis russia we've heard a
lot of tough words
today um really a
significant
eu pep talk
but how hard this position has really
become not in words
but indeed
we will know
in the weeks and months to come
i give the floor next on behalf of the
left group to martin scherdivan
thank you very much madam president
we're looking into the abyss of a war
between russia and
ukraine which the price of which will be
paced by the civil population above all
and the key to overcome this crisis
which challenges the entire
peaceful
architecture in europe is lies in
de-escalation
and verbal and military disarmament it
doesn't just go for the current
efforts to ensure peace but also for
past years in which relations between
the west and russia
have
systematically worsened the exclusion
from russia from the g8
the um
consolation of the meeting of the
nato
russia council and the normandy format
um are signs of the failure of democracy
a new
cold war
was
started in europe which might become a
hot
hot war
weber um
and
looked at a time where your european
powers um
negotiated
with the soviet union before the um
breakup of the eastern bloc
and there were oral
assurances made that nato wouldn't
expand one meter we know um
14 central european
central and eastern european countries
have joined nato since the 90s the
geostrategic architecture
and you can
capco as you wish and the west has
changed in the last 30 years with all
sides must work on a
peace
structure which recognizes the
multilateral nature of our world which
is based on law and recognizes the
legitimate um security concerns of all
nato isn't the national international um
justice um this is down to international
law i would have like it in this debate
to be stated clearly um
to deal with this crisis we need to have
preparedness to
maintain peace
russia must guarantee the security of
its neighbors and
ukraine must implement the misc minsk
agreement the idea of a eastern
expansion of nato won't uh contribute to
the security of europe it'll lead to the
destabilization of there won't be peace
in europe
uh there will be there only have peace
with russia
if we
thinking of the um
uh discussion yesterday but with the
german chancellor and putin
as an attack by russia on
russia
um
against ukraine it would be against
international law it would damage the
russian interests and the european um
peace
structure but putin must know this but
we know from bitter experience
that successful
can't
be based on
this type of thing um
facts are the basis of peace
not rumors we know that the
u.s
gas companies
have a boom
investors are celebrating at the cost of
european security the lesson of this is
that european security interests
aren't the same of
us interests necessarily european
interests must be decided by us
without transatlantic um
obedience
energy security is not based on russia
or
u.s gas but on the
rapid expansion of renewable energies
peace in europe must be decided here in
european capitals and not in
washington or in nato hq thank you very
much i give the floor now to andrea
boxcar on behalf of the non-attached
members
of
the european union and
its member states have their security
directly linked to ukraine's security
ukraine being an important partner
for the eu that is why we are
so incredibly concerned with the tension
that we are witnessing on the borders of
ukraine
hungary
needs to support dialogue to avoid war a
peaceful solution is the only
way forward and the minx agreement must
be implemented there's no alternative to
this
otherwise
we would find ourselves in a situation
of enormous material loss as has already
been the case in the
past now
in the uh confrontation there have been
many deaths already
many displaced people
and
galloping inflation covered the increase
in gas prices all of this has made
the situation of the people in the
ukraine
absolutely understand
unsustainable and also of the hungarian
people
that are there
and we must support a ukraine thank you
miss
name
here's the next speaker
dear colleagues
happy to have european family heads
and members together to express
solidarity with the ukrainian people
that
are like us
and want to live
like us in the same european family
the eu founding fathers have assumed
their leadership to unite entire
democratic western europe
now it is the time for us
to assume a similar leadership
to unite all democracies in the european
continent
because without strong ukraine there
will be no strong europe
the eu will be as strategically strong
as will be able to become an important
actor there
it is not the time for naive
chamberlains or illusions that relations
with putin scrambling can be mutually
productive or that their concessions
will help
it is important that the west remains
united in solidarity even if this
escalation will end without military
action
we must agree on what leading role the
eu must play and what can it do help
ukraine and other countries striving for
eu membership
if europe will return to business as
usual with the kremlin
we will be doomed to a circle of hybrid
and not only hybrid wars
also an intensive treatment for eu is
necessary including saving eu from
cancer cells the kremlin controlled
has
already today putin deserves a tribunal
for threatening to start a war to kill
people for navalny who is symbol of a
poisoned and imprisoned russia and for
whom i wish trench i thank the
ukrainians and slava ukrainian
thank you for our colleague
thank you very much
now
mr marcus
the floor is yes
thank you
chair mr representative commissioner
the threat of an invasion of ukraine
reminds us of the coldest days of the
cold war
and we feel that
the constant threat no one would like to
go back to that well let us say hardly
anyone
putin and his
comrades
seem to still be
keen and on that enormous border in the
ukraine they are carrying out the
biggest military exercises in many years
threatening ukraine and
the world as a whole
from the european union and with our
transatlantic partners the message has
been heard
and we must be united only in that way
will be able to rise to this challenge
our message is not a message of war but
just reminding mr putin that a war will
not be done in impunity our message is
not one of threat but we will not
feel intimidated by russia
our message is for dialogue and for
international law diplomacy and that
through this we will
avoid confrontation and resolve problems
and find solutions this is the way
forward and the way in which the
parliament and the european union is
presenting to the to russia for a
solution with a good sense and realism
and with full respect for independence
and the territorial integrity of ukraine
now
pertinent putin we are sure he will make
the right a choice and um
both for ukraine europe and for russia
thank you
thank you now
mr ostervichus
mr chair high representative
commissioner dear colleagues
never be clear to all
ukraine is part of the european
family
as belarus too
ukraine security is europe's security
and it's
off it's all of concern to all of us
the military threat posed by russia to
ukraine only confirms the hopelessness
and aggressiveness of the kremlin
i very much hope that the west has
seized the opportunity to learn the
lesson of unity
solidarity and common response
we will need this lesson in the future
because putin seems to have neither the
will
nor the interest to change
by giving ukraine
the opportunity to reform
on the basis of european experience and
partnership
we are supporting and investing
in the future of the democratic and
prosperous ukraine
were enabling the country and its people
to follow the path they embarked on back
in 2014 with a revolution of dignity
ukrainians decides
their own future
and i'm strongly convinced
that the future of ukraine
is not
finlandization
it's europeation
slavo ukrainian thank you
thank you for our colleagues thank you
very much miss
von kramen tabadel
is the next
speaker high representative
war is so unjust and ugly
that all who wage it
must try to stifle the ways of conscious
within themselves
these words belong to one of the
greatest pacifists leotos toy who
ironically also happens to be the one
that president putin claims to have
influenced him most
evidently the russian president has
stifled his voice of conscience and
brought our continent of the to the
brink of war
how else could he summon 135
000 soldiers on the ukrainian border
ukraine is a great country of great
people today this is stronger than ever
it stands up for itself and will only be
stronger tomorrow this is the reason of
the kremlin's war mongering putin knows
if he does not take over ukraine no now
he won't be able to do so in the future
what the russian president sees as a
window of opportunity can be a lethal
trap for his country ukraine will be for
russia what afghanistan was for the
soviet union an imperial overstretched a
painful end of putin's empire
war is not only unjust and ugly but also
senseless as there are no winners it
brings only destruction and suffering to
people on both sides if putin starts the
war common russians will have to suffer
the consequences
russian mothers crying over their fallen
sons pensioners feeling the chilling
effects of western sanctions ukrainians
are strong because they fight for their
country they do not stand alone because
they have reliable friends and above all
because they have the truth on their
side thank you
thank you
mr madison is the next speaker
thanks so much mr president mr burrell
unfortunately mrs swandelayan has left
already
i was listening very carefully the
speeches
and i would like to mention especially
two things uh first of all mrs
vanderlaan mentioned that russia is now
weaponizing the energy policy
well i would like to say well what we
told you about five six years ago
if we're gonna build up the north stream
two between germany russia of course
they will weaponize it that's obvious
there is no energy policy without other
policies also with economical policy
defense policy
that's that's very clear
but chairman's
wants you to build up the nordstrom 2
with russia and here we are now of
course they're weaponizing it i think to
make it as like a big surprise i think
it's a bit like ridiculous
secondly um
everybody has mentioned that uh
we are ready for everything also miss
vandalia and mr borrell mentioned that
we are ready for every scenario
hopefully we are but on the other hand
if you look on the facts
when estonia
just wanted to give some military help
to ukraine
who blocked it
german government
german government said no no you will
not give it because it was our military
equipment on the 80s on the soviet time
part of the eastern germany and will not
give it to ukraine
so i really don't see like this harmony
inside of the eu
of course it's very very clear fact that
russia is at rest
but i don't i really don't think that we
have to panic here but we have to be
ready for everything that's also obvious
uh also like the previous speakers when
they when they tell that
the war is uh
senseless it's pointless of course for
us it's pointless but
i think we take it too emotionally
he doesn't really think what's really
what russia wants to have
like
even if you look at the troops 135 000
troops next to the ukrainian border of
course it's not enough to occupy all the
ukraine it's not enough ukraine is
totally different country compared what
they were eight years ago
they have made a really good progress on
the right side
but
135 000 troops are very enough just to
make some small actions in the eastern
ukraine if you look what they are doing
in russian parliament they are now
recognizing legally donetsk and luhansk
as independent countries
it takes only a few days maybe when they
are risk they are asking for the help
military help because the ukrainian
government will maybe attack those
independent countries and this 135
thousand troops are very enough for
small actions in the military thank you
so much
thank you
thank you
the next speaker is vice president zile
brexit
mr pro chairman uh high representative
uh
ukraine today has the day of unity what
is it about
it's about the ukrainian people wanting
to take a path of western democracy and
their democratically elected government
and president is lead are leading them
but
the ukrainian government needs our
support through this day of unity
because it might be that the kremlin
believes that the ukraine should be
freed from junta
uh as it's sometimes said unofficially
and
this is the moment
when we
have to
lend a hand to ukrainians
and our declarations
should clearly state that the doors
european union are open for ukraine of
course it's not happening very quickly
but still these doors have to be open
and we should provide not only
financially but including also support
with some weapons
well then the question about not
irritating or annoying russia the
ukrainian president had a chance to
visit this house this week but i believe
uh that somehow our extended hand to
ukraine is shaking which is not good
news for the ukrainian people and let's
be realistic in the midterm we should
change our energy policy and very soon
thank you
thank you
thank you
the next speaker is mr pineda
thank you president
we have flown extremely close to having
the two major nuclear powers of the
world entering into open conflict using
europe as its chess board
and i speak in the past tense because
the us and its military arm nato have
run out of arguments for the wars that
they would like to start but they don't
they've never really needed them have
they the u.s continues to mount wars
from very far away from its national
territory and many european governments
have acted irresponsibly pouring a fuel
on the fire
nato is using europe and specifically
its borders with russia as a huge
military base at the service of
commercial and military
and geostat strategic interests that are
not of those of europe mr borow we have
many differences in opinion
but i still consider you a man of peace
who seeks to resolve conflict through
political means so i ask you now to not
allow the eu to become
either the
troops the military base or the chess
board for this a war machine that is in
uh endangering the very existence of the
planet thank you
thank you
thank you
we now
go to mr papadakis
we have the
obvious danger of a war on the ukrainian
border that thing has to do
with the the fight for energy between
nato the u.s and russia but no side on
this conflict is on the side of the
peoples
also the eu may play the peace dove but
it has led
in wars in afghanistan syria and
elsewhere we now have a new american
base in alexandropolis in greece
where american and nato troops are
surrounding russia and it has been
signed by the current and the previous
greek government and that means danger
for the greek people
the people should also fight to
drive all the foreign military bases out
of greece
do not sign a new
agreement with the us bring back our
troops and stop the imperialist plans of
the us and the eu
the people should come to
power thank you
thank you
here in the room mr ghana
it has now been an eight-year period
that the world has witnessed a
systematic multi-faceted russian policy
of invading destabilizing and demonizing
ukraine the reason is not that ukraine
was a military threat to russia or that
russian speakers were discriminated such
claims are wrong nor should we buy the
argument that nato membership was such
threat we know it is not our weapons but
it is the power of the values and the
attractiveness of democratic societies
that pose an existential threat to a
repressive russian state structure
behind whose potemkin forsade anything
goes
yesterday putin left all options on the
table in the press conference of the
german chancellor he continued his
obvious lie that a genocide was ongoing
in the donbas his interpretation of
history deprives ukrainians of all
features of statehood claiming it was
one people one empire one language one
church no mr putin it is not
let us now be prudent
and with the implementation of the minsk
accord that does not exert undue
pressure on ukraine in order to appease
russian claims
they cannot hand out hundreds of
thousands of passports to the citizens
of lugansk and donetsk and claim the
recognition of these russian bantu
stands and at the same time demand from
ukraine to grant a special status to
this region
ukrainians must stand together against
the external threat
but they need also to put their internal
dis
divisions aside now it is not the time
for nitty-gritty parties in infighting
join forces and implement the ambitious
reform agenda that will make you one day
an irresistible european country that
enjoys all perspectives of a common
future we stand with ukraine slavokreini
thank you
your colleague
yes thank you very much
i'd now like to hand the floor to mr
tonino picula
thank you mr chair mr high
representative mr commissioner
our relations with russia have been at
low point for a while
most political challenges at our
external borders have directly or
indirectly russia is a common
denominator
the list of open issues is long
disinformation hybrid threats funding of
anti-democratic forces in the eu and
foreign interference but today our
primary focus should be ukraine after
eight year war with 14 000 victims
situation in and around ukraine evolved
into global threat
russia is also actively undermining
ukraine's democratic and socio-economic
development for years through political
and economic means as well as through
this information
so what can we best help ukraine in this
crisis
despite the lack of progress there is no
alternative to continued talks
diplomacy is still the only credible way
to avoid doomsday scenarios meanwhile
european union has to continue
supporting ukraine building deterrence
boosting ukraine's economy and defense
supporting reform processes as well
we also should
work to increase potential cost of
russian aggressions by introducing
sanctions against individuals banks and
companies involved in plans to attack
ukraine halting non-stream 2 in a case
of progression would increase our
leverage while doing all of the above
ukraine is a sovereign country with
internationally recognized borders that
has a fully right to decide on its
geopolitical orientation
the ongoing crisis has shown once again
that any local crisis in europe can turn
into a global threat with possible
deteriorating consequences this should
be an urgent call for the eu to enhance
our own ability to respond quickly and
in a unified way
while awaiting much needed comprehensive
eu strategy towards russia we stand with
ukraine thank you
thank you
yes thank you very much
mrs natalie lazor has the floor now
thank you president
dear joseph
ukraine does not want a war neither does
europe nor does the united states and i
am deeply convinced that the russian
people also wish to have peace
so 130 000 russian troops are amassed on
the ukraine borders and we've seen
military
drills in belarus and we've seen a lot
of
naval presence as well
bhutan has said that he will withdraw
some of his troops but we have seen that
new demands are being put forward and
putin is denouncing an alleged genocide
in donbass which only
exists in his imagination it's putin and
him alone
that is willing to avail of force there
have been all sorts of diplomatic
efforts uh mr michael mr schulze
and
if anything happens putin will be the
only person responsible for this he will
have to bear the consequences
he threatens ukraine not because nato is
um
wishing to expand but there's far more
than that
kiev is turning his back to russia and
looking towards europe
and
ukraine does not want to go back to the
soviet union that's not its dream it's
dreaming of the european union
dear colleagues we're the greatest hope
for ukraine
and i would like to solemnly apply to
you that we do not disappoint ukraine
ukraine
[Applause]
thank you
the next speaker
is mrs heidi hautella
despite the
speeches we just heard that the eu has
operated together despite this these
speeches
i think it's clear for me that the eu is
not acting with his whole weight
nato is central to this crisis and the
eu is weakened by the fact that six
member states are not nato members
some of these member states might still
believe in neutrality even though the
facts do
no longer speak for this
some of these
hope that the eu will become a defense
union this aspiration is not
supported by the facts either
therefore colleagues i think it's very
important that nato should
invite all its
members that are not members to join
what putin has already achieved is that
in finland for example there has been a
clear shift towards nato and as you know
for years as finland has been a close
partner of nato
it's necessary that in this uh situation
we show unshakable
support for ukraine its uh territorial
integrity and sovereignty we have to
stand as one and show that
we um are serious in our counter
reactions and sanctions must have faced
uh putin and his inner circle and also
include gas a cooperation in gas and
nuclear energy
thank you
thank you president colleagues now
france hasn't made any progress
diplomatically following president
macron's visit to russia and ukraine and
basically that leaves us on the back
foot now we must
remember that the german navy had was
dismissed because he had a different uh
position on the subject and how are we
supposed to interpret the fact that
there's been a call for people to
evacuate the embassies in ukraine now if
there were to be an invasion the
surprise of the effective surprise will
uh would have been helpful now president
macron
met with the
russian president but then we saw that
that there were two different versions
in terms of what happened during that
and then the spokesperson said that the
statements were inexact now if we look
at what's happening
in the us we can see that there is a
distance between uh that there's a that
there is an attempt to keep a distance
between the us and russia on the one
hand we would like to turn off the
faucet of nordstrom 2 and on the other
hand we are buying gas from qatar and
algeria that are not very well known for
their democratic values so if we look at
what is happening for the kiev we're
seeing that they're basically beginning
being given an iv of eu funds
now this urgency vote uh to give mfa to
ukraine for to the tune of 1.2 billion
is a perfect example of this but that's
not the only one we have to remember
also that there is some
17 billion that was paid out in terms of
grants and loans that will never be
reimbursed even though the court of
auditors said that there was a
misappropriation of funds used for
corruption and i'd like to conclude by
stating that nobody would like to see a
war in europe thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
the next speaker is mr vashtikovsky
yes thank you very much
for some time now very many of us have
been talking about sanctions on russia
for the blackmail against ukraine and
part of europe
unfortunately following the visit of
chancellor schultz to moscow i cease to
believe that these sanctions will ever
come into play
and then we have support for ukraine but
we only seem to be sending
expressions of political solidarity to
ukraine
but i'm glad that we have been talking
about greater financial support for
ukraine but i think the time has come
for us to strengthen cooperation
further cooperation with ukraine and to
help them build up their opportunities
we have to open up a path to ukraine for
um accession
in the european union for ukraine mulder
and georgia i think perhaps we could
start off by
looking at the um
[Music]
the three
baltic
city
state
baltic sea city initiative and also look
at other opportunities the agencies
and i think another step would be to
link these countries to the single
market
following the swiss example and then of
course accession to the european union
according to the copenhagen criteria the
economic success of ukraine has is
necessary
and we have to this has to be a
possibility for them as an alternative
to russia and obviously this would be
good for europe and ukraine and
obviously uh putin wouldn't like this at
all so we have to stop that for russia
mr mick wallace
we've had three months of this farce now
and the line between the real and the
imaginary is blurred
the us and the uk have used our media to
flood pages screens and airwaves with a
load of unsubstantiated fear mongering
and lies lean from unaccountable
anonymous sources in the intelligence
community
this is really such a pitch that when
ukraine begs the us and nato to stop
creating hysteria and to provide some
proof for the supposedly imminent any
day now russian invasion ukraine is
ignored by the forces that pretend to
protect them
nato's race on debt is protecting
western corporate interest and the
interest of the military-industrial
complex but it looks like now they're
also protecting the interest of u.s gas
and oil
the war mongeri and nato the
warmongering of nato and the us these
past few months has done nothing for
peace in europe and the role played by
neighborhood think tanks like atlantic
council was not good
people who want peace in europe should
be calling for nato to be abolished
our next i'm sorry
thank you the next speaker is milan
urich
mili progressive
dear uh progressive anti-russian war
mongerers
for several months you've been talking
about how russia wants to attack ukraine
for several months liberal media write
articles about russia as a demon that is
threatening the whole of europe and a
couple of days ago american president
biden
uh published a prophecy that today today
the russian federation
would attack ukraine what happened
nothing and i'll tell you on behalf of
more than half of the citizens of
slovakia according to current statistics
we are up to here
and this is a message to all the the
american war mongers and their lackeys
in europe to pack the american army and
leave europe and not drag us into their
conflicts and their wars europe wants
peace please
what these provocations serve in ukraine
look at the hungarian prime minister
orban how peacefully and constructively
he negotiated in moscow about the
cooperation about lower prices of
energies this is the way that the
european union should take cooperation
rather than war
the next speaker is mr andreas kubilius
dear colleagues
today we need to understand
that russian the putin
is a declining post-imperial power
russian the putin is a desperate new
sick man of europe internally putin is
afraid of navalny externally he is
afraid of the example of success of
democratic ukraine
authoritarian russia under putin is a
bigger threat to security on our
continent putin will not change himself
threats ukraine will continue during the
years to come because this is a way how
kremlin aims to weaken ukrainian economy
future of democracy in russia not a
dialogue with autocratic putin is a
long-term goal for a new security
architecture in europe
strong and able to defend itself ukraine
will deter kremlin aggression since only
the weakness of its opponents is
provoking putin for further threats and
aggression
that is why the west must invest into
political military economical success of
ukraine eu integration is the only way
to create such a success of democratic
ukraine for that purpose
the eu should put forward focusing a new
process of accelerated integration at
the beginning of integration into the eu
single market
such an integration strategy focusing is
the most effective long-term strategy
without to deter russia european
integration and western unity is a
unique european instrument to keep
long-term peace on european continent
slava ukraine
thank you colleague thank you very much
mr sven mixer for two minutes please
colleagues
we have said always that we support
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
and inevitably the notion of sovereignty
includes a country's right to choose its
own alliances
ukraine's your atlantic aspirations are
fully legitimate no threat to anyone and
their realization must be conditional
only on ukraine's performance not the
third country veto
russia's massive military buildup on
ukraine's borders has brought our
continent closer to a large-scale
military conflict than at any time since
the end of the cold war
it's only natural that we want to
de-escalate this situation
but we must act in a way that will
really result in the escalation
appeasing the bully or considering to
her more territory or more control
will not bring about sustainable
de-escalation
in fact it would only give the aggressor
a signal that the intimidation tactic
works
what we need is a strong collective
deterrent posture by the community of
intern democratic nations
deterrence is not by nature escalatory
its aim is to discourage the potential
aggressor by changing her calculus by
delivering an unambiguous message that
the cost of waging an act of aggression
far outweighs any benefit it might be
expected to bring
i do believe that president putin is a
rational player who will not rush into a
conflict that is bound to bring him more
pain than gain
a strong deterrent posture consists of
two main parts the first is a clear and
united message to russia that a new
aggression will result in a decisive
response from the international
community
inevitably that response must include a
package of crippling sanctions
the second part is bolstering ukraine's
ability to defend itself
again i want to stress that a more
confident ukraine with stronger
defensive capabilities will reduce not
increase the likelihood of a new
aggression by russia we must be strong
and united
it may appear to some that doing nothing
is a peaceful act in reality nothing is
further from the truth
thank you
the next
speaker is mr bernard guetta
high representative colleagues let us
accept our successes now let us
accept that we are humiliated but rather
shall we we should look at and
understand our strength
we are united in lockstep
in a way that we haven't been in a very
long time between europeans and the us
and we have really forced mr putin to
reflect we raised the risk of sanctions
and
a direct discussion between russia and
china and the interests of russia and
now
the president has come back to
discussing diplomacy and uh agreement mr
putin we are
poised to discuss security but let us
not discuss your um
alleged concerns but rather
the
massing of troops as well as your
denial
to your neighbors to decide their own
associations allow us to reassure your
neighbors allow us to let them accept
their freedom and avoid any threats or
or oppression as has taken place in
belarus
now mr putin we know that you have
concerns of course but all we hope for
is peace stability and cooperation
amongst uh partners and allies we must
now consult
and finalize our proposals that we will
put to you and we will be prepared but
peace a durable peace
must benefit our common continent it is
now the ball is now in your court mr
putin
thank you
to vodka
dear colleagues
the one positive thing about these weeks
is that we are
talking
but history will judge us
only if we think beyond short term
yes in the short term we have to
overcome the current crisis and talking
and negotiating especially the tough
negotiations that we're experiencing is
a great great step forward
but what about the mid-term
how do we make sure
that we have a sustainable solution
and we do not allow russia to repeat
threatening posture vis-a-vis ukraine
and its other neighbors again and again
and again
we must make clear that we can only
return to business as usual if russia
will seize its propaganda crusade
against ukraine its threats against
ukraine and its lies against ukraine
just as we heard the lie about a alleged
genocide or discrimination of russian
speakers which are not true
we have to do everything possible that
the black male that we are experienced
seeing will not be repeating itself and
yes we must start thinking about how to
develop the minsk agreement beyond the
mantra that we've been repeating so far
because we need a tool that is effective
in the midterm and in the long term we
will have to engage with russia where we
can but we must disengage where we must
and we must disengage also in the energy
area that's why not stream 2 is not part
of sanctions not stream 2 is
unacceptable no matter what thank you
thank you
yes thank you very much
i'd now like to hand the floor to mr
harold velinsky
dear colleagues
discussing ukraine and russia
i think we ought to
think back to 2003
2003 when the then u.s president mr bush
and the defense defense minister mr
powell
and tony blair the uk prime minister
lied to the world and took us into the
iraq war
we should also think back
to
2014
following maidan
where ukraine
was newly ordered as it were and the son
of the
current
uh president
hunter biden was involved in ukraine
energy companies
and the u.s
irenko
was received a different citizenship
on the eve of the same day then
uh became
the finance minister in ukraine so as
you can see from all these convoluted
goings on then it's all about interests
and basically business interests as an
austrian i would like to add that i come
from a country
which is obliged to neutrality
and i like
the russians and americans equally
and
obviously what i want is to guarantee
peace in the long term in europe
but i don't think we in europe should be
turned into the ball
which is being hit back between russia
and the united states
that's not good for europe the continent
or the european union
i think in my opinion what would be
helpful is to solve this
conflict without the
um participation of the states
because what we've heard from the biden
administration is one provocation after
another
obviously we don't want uh further
expansion the east on the part of nato
and uh i think what i would suggest this
is my last word is the tripolar
conference between the europeans the
russians and the ukrainians and then
have this on a more permanent basis so
that we don't become
a kind of geopolitical ball of financial
interests
the next speaker is mrs anafortiga
thank you
putin's
russia
supporting ethnic cleansings then
self-determination
using hybrid hybrid war political
corruption
and
energy blackmail against the west
killing opponents on our territories
the aggressor
always preempting non-existent
strikes in its
propaganda
we have to stay united and firm
i stand
by ukraine they know it
i stand by people of belarus and free
georgian society the european parliament
should reiterate its long-standing
position
on nordstream 2 to hold it immediately
not in case
immediately because it is the very bad
project and the message sent in this
dangerous time to russia may be very bad
with delusion of our position thank you
thank you
thank you
mark botenga you have the floor sir
in ukraine
in the diplomacy de-escalation is
necessary in ukraine in in diplomacy
this means
speaking with unpleasant people
shall michelle says that hundreds of
millions
must be mobilized to bring ukraine into
the western
sphere of influence the greens uh the
left
uh have supported this
but they've forgotten the basic
principles well we must imagine what if
um
hundreds of millions
uh were to be mobilized by russia to get
mexico for example in the sphere
influence
we must think about this sort of thing
europe
has understood that austria finland
the the
neutrality was correct but we've
forgotten this lesson ukraine
should be integrated into nato and this
will lead to a conflict
we must negotiate
they shouldn't extend nato
we should have a
common
peace structure in europe
thank you
the next speaker is miroslav radakovsky
dear colleagues
it is the 16th of february 2022 there is
no attack on ukraine we don't know what
happens in the afternoon though
yesterday on the 15th
of february the ambassador the
ambassador of ukraine in the parliament
of slovak slavic republic said and i
quote ukraine has no information about
any impending attack of russia into
ukraine as mentioned by the
representatives of the us and he
continues uh such statements of the u.s
uh
cost the ukraine half a billion
usd us dollars every day maybe maybe
someone should
send a note to the to our u.s partners
that this information is never useful
the hatred between politicians is slowly
trickling down into hatred between
nations a great son of the polish nation
pope
john paul ii
on the 22nd of april 1990 when he
visited czechoslovakia at that time said
and i quote
cold war is over
nobody should feel the loser nobody
should feel a winner because this uh
division into winners and losers can
only lead to a renewed hatred between
east and west john paul ii then says
a healthy body breeds with both
sides of the lung left and right if one
side is sick the whole body gets sick
and
me as a conservative politician follow
the great
uh polish son's words i am for a
diplomatic solution of these problems
here at the highland
thank you
i'd now like to hand the floor to the
chair of the foreign affairs committee
of the european parliament david
mcallister
thank you mr
president
as many colleagues from different
political groups have underlined this
morning
the current tensions the current
escalating tensions and the threat of an
unprecedented military aggression by the
russian federation against ukraine
are indeed
not only targeting ukraine
but also threatening the rules-based
international order
and threatening europe as a whole
and this is why we must stand together
in this crucial moment
as european parliament we will not waver
in our support of ukraine's independence
sovereignty and territorial integrity
within its internationally recognized
borders
ukraine has a sovereign right to choose
its international alliances freely
the russian federation must seize its
military threat against ukraine and
immediately as well as fully withdraw
its forces and military equipment from
the border of ukraine
any further military aggression
against ukraine would have massive and
unprecedented consequences and severe
costs and response including restrictive
measures coordinated with our
international partners
it is on the kremlin
to de-escalate and to engage
constructively for established
mechanisms the double track of
diplomatic engagement and deterrence
remains key to solving the current
situation
final remark colleagues
following monday's vote to apply an
urgent procedure we are now this noon
set to give the green light to an
emergency 1.2 billion euro loan to
ukraine to cover its
external financing needs in 2022 this
demonstrates our solidarity and support
for ukraine and the ukrainian people
thank you
[Applause]
the next speaker is mr chimoshevich
regardless of how the current crisis
ends that has been triggered by russia's
threat to invade ukraine
it will be high time for us to draw the
conclusions that from this further
lesson for several years russia has been
carrying out a rather quarrelsome
foreign policy continuously surprising
other countries in particular western
countries by their actions
and it's always they who take the action
the initiative and we are left to react
and if we add to that
the general opportunism dictated by
financial and economic interests and the
desire just to uh brush away problems
and if we season this mixture with a
lack of knowledge knowledge of russia
and a naivety suggesting that you can
always manage somehow to come to an
understanding with them then the end
result is
an ineffective policy which russia
treats with disdainful disregard for the
first time the west's reaction has have
been announced to a possible aggression
by russia including a threat which is
really of really serious and costly
sanctions which putin cannot ignore when
weighing losses and gains in my opinion
we should go further and credibly
threaten the interest of the corrupt
elite europe must also actively pursue
independence from russia's energy
supplies
a country which violates international
law robs their neighbors of part of
their territory appeals to brutal armed
force corrupts parties and politicians
in our countries which wages an
intensive campaign of lies in the
digital sphere cannot be regarded as a
reliable and trusted partner the
security of our energy systems cannot
depend on the whim of an autocratic
leader in russia it's time for us to
take the initiative for complex and
joint action today we are urgently
helping ukraine and tomorrow we should
give serious thought to how to eliminate
the reasons and the cause of our
helplessness in the face of the threats
from my quarrelsome neighbor thank you
[Applause]
thank you
the next speaker is miss foutmans
dear hi representative dear colleagues
a lot have been set already and for me
it's very clear if we want to become a
real geopolitical player we need to get
our act together by making us
less reliable on russian gas supply by
building a sheet against russian attacks
and most importantly by setting up a
real european defense union we have to
believe in the power of europe
but what really worries me mr burrell
is that putin does not want to speak to
europe he simply refused
and that we know him
last week president macron was in moscow
yesterday chancellor schultz was in
moscow but actually it should have been
europe at that long table we would be
much stronger if we talked to russia if
you talked to russia mr bell on behalf
of europe with one voice and i'm sure mr
burrell you agree with that
that is why i have three questions mr
braille have you been in contact with
the leadership of germany and france
can you confirm they have presented
putin with a common eu front and can you
confirm they have not give mr putin an
inch thank you very much
thank you very much
the next speaker is mr ropey
thank you madam chairman
their colleagues
the kremlin is instigating military
conflicts
they are instigating political murders
they are destroying the last
remain remaining pieces of democracy in
their own country and they are
manipulating gas prices using that as a
measure to pressure us and they're also
profiting a lot from the gas export
putin wants to decide
what will be the future of sovereign
countries i would like to ask a straight
question why is this so
is this because europe is always trying
to
to um find its own way
and not to anger russia because it's
dependent on russia's resources
one will europe have strategic autonomy
and when will europe be able to fight
aggressive regimes not with words but
with actions
slav ukrainian
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker
is mr kofo
tag for the foreman thank you madam
president
many speakers have already underlined
the serious situation we're in
a situation
where there's a risk
that it can become worse
i would like to
express my deep sympathy and support for
ukraine
because of course
a country should always have the
possibility to choose its own
destiny its own future
irrespective of what its neighbors think
and of course this also applies to
ukraine
i think the most important thing for
european uh security defense is our
alliance with the americans and the
british it is our cooperation in nato
which i would like to see prioritized
but that's up to our own countries to
deal with that
where has where would europa have been
if it hadn't been for the americans and
the british
this alliance
is
so uh
terribly important in this situation
and
more important than ever before
i also have to say that i'm amazed in
germany they have the idea that they can
divide energy policy split it off from
other policies they think that they can
talk about energy on the one side and
that it has no influence on security and
foreign policy of course it has things
are interlinked
and
in particular night where energy is so
expensive
it has
extreme importance
um
when we're talking about becoming
independent in the next few years the
u.s president has also pointed it out to
the new german chancellor and i think
there's a knee
i hope in germany
they will have a broader debate about
nordstrom 2
because as i see it
it's impossible to imagine that you can
divide energy policy from defence policy
thank you very much
thank you very much mr kofi
now we go to madrid
and mr turch
thank you very much president weakness
produces monsters and european weakness
along with the weakness of the current
u.s administration has invited putin to
show his worst side
we've seen the first chapter of this
drama under obama when he let himself be
trampled over and all of his red lines
trampled on in syria and in what
happened in crimea and so
weakness produces monsters and we have
to stop putin
where he is his threat is not just
ukraine it's all of europe and all of
western europe poland lithuania the
baltics
uh bulgaria and romania we need to state
to putin that he cannot threat countries
that are internationally recognized
inclu
including one country that is currently
occupied at this time and that we cannot
play with a certain european favors a
nordstrom that needs to be suspended
immediately
thank you
the next speaker is mr williamson
befriending
the population in ukraine
deserve peace and freedom the current
russian aggression
the annexation of the crimea and the
occupation of east ukraine is totally
unacceptable
putin is
exploiting the eu country's dependence
on russian gas if we want to detach
ourselves from putin it's essential that
we strength strengthen the green
transition and make ourselves uh
independent of fossil fuels they can't
go quick quick enough with north stream
two the eu
paradoxically is increasing its
dependence on russian gas and at the
same time
with the military buildup this could go
terribly wrong
we
owe the ukrainian people to do all we
can to avoid war let us strengthen the
diplomatic efforts let us stop
this headlong
armament
mr burrell let's
put
putin and the oligarchs in their place
and stop nordstrom 2
once and for all
thank you
the next speaker is mr yung kyusi
thank you chair
in yalta exactly 77 years ago super
powers divided europe for half a century
ushered in the era of cold war and
shoved central eastern europe behind the
iron curtain against its will
once again russia is aiming to divide
our continent by extending its sphere of
influence
putin is reviving the brezhnev doctrine
and the cold war rhetoric
mr borel you mentioned exemplary unity
and solidarity within the eu
while we have victor orban acting as a
fifth column within our community
echoing moskov's position blocking nato
initiatives downplaying the impact of
sanctions betraying not only its allies
but over a hundred thousand hungarians
living in ukraine's zakarpattia
i was happy to hear mr legutko speaker
for ecr to recount the european
collaborators of moscow
representatives of peace the polish
ruling party could help the eu by
influencing their key ally in hungary
viktor orban they are our best hope at
least in this regard until the hungarian
elections on the 3rd of april thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
the next speaker is mr
malam president colleagues
we tried to integrate so
post-soviet russia into our community we
admitted russia into the council of
europe we signed partnership and
cooperation agreement we were ready to
sign partnership and cooperation
agreement two which would have been an
association agreement in orbat name
but mr putin has gone the way of
conquest
and that of course has to be countered i
welcome the words of
the president of the uh european
commission that we need to become more
independent in the energy sphere
european
defense is one thing but what we really
need is a gas union
just as the commission buys uranium on
behalf of member states and then
distributes
it among member states we could be using
the power of monopsony of being the
largest client customer for russian gas
i call on germany to overcome the
selfish logic of nordstrom 2 and to
become the leader of the gas union this
would be good for the environment good
for the european economy good for member
states we would all get gas cheaper
and good for our standing
with mr putin he will not change his
mind thanks to partnerships between
cities
it's not the language he understands he
will change his behavior if we confront
him with actions not just words thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much
the next speaker is mr olekos
thank you madam chair
dear colleagues once again be discussing
a crisis in the center of europe created
by russia
and trying our best to avoid any
unnecessary confrontation
once again we see a flow of european
and world leaders to meet the biggest
european bully
and we have clapping our hands with the
relief if he decide to move echelons of
his soldiers a few hundred kilometers
from the ukrainian borders
of course we should use all our
diplomatic means
to achieve the peaceful ending of the
current crisis
i believe
we can
achieve this only by being united
in our response
we should push even more for a common
approach to any security crisis
for this reason we have to ask
governments of our member states to
dedicate adequate attention and
financial resources to the defense
sector
we also have free ourselves from the big
dependency on the one big supply in any
areas of our life including energy for
that reason i am welcome the efforts of
eu diversification of energy supply
as a european security system cannot be
decided in the corridors of kremlin
the same way the patch of ukrainian
cannot be decided in kremlin 2.
ukraine's future should depend on the
choice of its people
but the eu
has the right and the moral obligation
to stress again that ukraine has a place
among european family
and europe will help ukraine in these
difficult times in all possible means
financially in expertise and which
defense military equipment
thank you and ukraine
thank you very much the next speaker is
mr asmani
yes thank you very much uh
madam president dear high representative
mr burrell and also dear vice president
commissioner mr shinos and their
colleagues
we have all witnessed the escalating
pressure on ukraine and putin is without
doubt playing
a very dangerous game of brickmanship
what is he really trying to achieve
well nobody knows besides putin himself
and what we do know
is that putting
a gun to ukraine's head is no way to
preserve peace in europe or to enhance
russia's security
one misstep
one mistake
and putin could unleash a devastating
conflict that jeopardized our collective
safety and stability
that is why the union needs to support
ukraine in any way we can
complete the list of severe sanctions
increase financial support for ukraine
but we will
and enhance the defensive capabilities
of the ukraine
i commend high representative burrell
for the his hard work in coordinating
also with our transatlantic partners and
i call on our member states to maintain
our unity and to stand firm if we want
to prevent a new war in europe thank you
very much
thank you colleague i must remind you
about the importance to stick to your
speaking time because we have
understandably a very long list of
speakers still ahead of us
excuse me
the next speaker is miss gregorova
speaking from prague you have the floor
thank you very much chair dear
colleagues
we meet in this plenary on a day that
many have speculated over the past week
russia would invade ukraine
both those people that have experienced
war and those who would like to do
without that experience
feel their throats tighten at the
prospect
if we look at the list of security
threats over the past few years we would
search in vain for incidents that were
not acts of aggression by russian
federation think georgia think ukraine
spying scandals assassination on
european soil or disinformation
campaigns all these show kremlin's
handwriting
whichever way the current tension turns
it is important to remember that russia
has long been at war with european
countries just using non-traditional
methods and russia is winning
it is succeeding in dividing what
remains is to rule we must unite and
focus on both the short-term threats and
the long-term consequences of the
kremlin's actions otherwise we will lose
without a fight
thank you
the next speaker is mr simnyuk
the situation on the russian border with
ukraine is worrying
and very untransparent whether the
partial withdrawal of russian troops
will lead to a
durable
detont is unclear the situation uh to
improve this
we need several steps we need a
guarantee uh by ukraine that they will
not
accede to nato
the
sean mizheim
of the us said
no major power
would like to have another major power
as its neighbor
let's just imagine canada would have an
alliance with
russia the u.s would
be delighted about that
these the facts show nato
is mooting has been moving for decades
towards russia
and not the other way around a united
um
demonization of russia should be
rejected
the existing sanctions should
be rolled back
and to
remove this unnecessary tension
ukraine should be a neutral state
to have relations with moscow and
washington
um
not without being on any particular side
and to avoid a any conflict between the
two powers of course russia must be
aware of one thing the visa great states
the baltic states or our polish friends
if there were a russian aggression or
threat we would be definitely on
um
we'll be all together and let's be all
clear that war must be avoided at all
costs
thank you very much
the next speaker is miss schutler
yes thank you president dear colleagues
russia
lies closer to the european union than i
think those of us
can recall
politicians and those of us in this
particular house
and russia is
uh a dictator
he uses
the weaknesses and the naivety of us and
uh the lack of courage in
against him and i don't think there
should be any
illusions that
uh by saying that we won't
allow nord stream 2
to start that that will have any kind of
consequence i think we have to show
solidarity we have to be united and we
have to be unambiguous in our decisions
today we have to support ukraine and we
should not forget either that the policy
of the european union vis-a-vis russia
should be decisive and unambiguous
that's what europe needs today and
that's what ukraine needs today thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much
the next speaker is mr
gyorgyo
theater
commissioner
cia said that there would be a war today
no war happened uh
do some people need the war want a war
there's a lot of money in the sales of
natural gas the us is talking about
aggressiveness when they themselves
spend 800 billion
for their military they have 800 bases
abroad
and thousands of soldiers in europe miss
van der lion is threatening with
sanctions but who is going to pay the
coast it will be the european peoples
and the eu
is just the tail end of nato that is
simply watching what is happening in our
backyard president macron and councillor
seoul said it if russia is not safe the
european union will not be safe either
so history commands that europe should
stand on the side of peace we need a
diplomatic solution
right now
which will mean that nato will not
expand the eastwards and at the same
time the russian troops will fall back
we need to give
peace a chance thank you
thank you
the next speaker is mr morrison
thank you madam president dear
colleagues let us be clear what a
military aggression by russia against
ukraine means it means the instant
international isolation of the russian
federation it means political isolation
it means economic isolation for the
russian federation and we all know that
isolation brings poverty it means
poverty for the people of russia for 20
years the ruling of mr putin has let the
people of russia down today the average
salary in russia is smaller than the
average salary in any of the 27 member
states of the union today life
expectancy in russia is shorter than
life expectancy in any of the 27 member
states of the union and media in russia
is much less free than media in the
european union people in russia today
are living in worse conditions than the
people of the european union
this is the truth it needs to be told
and an aggression will mean an immediate
worsening of the living conditions in
russia people will be poorer very soon
we do not want this to happen but this
is what will inevitably happen if russia
invades ukraine colleagues we also need
to find ways to talk to the citizens of
russia we need a plan and this belongs
into the strategic compass of the
european union on telling the people of
russia why democracy why freedom of the
press why rule of law are good for them
and why peace is the first condition for
prosperity and for us dear colleagues
defending ukraine means defending
ourselves we can only live in safety
inside the borders of the european union
if we are surrounded by safe neighbors
we can only be safe within the borders
of the eu if ukraine is safe defending
ukraine means defending europe and
defending the european union thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you
the next speaker
is mr shida
thank you
thank you very much madam president
vice president
colleagues
as often said the situation is serious
the risk of war in eastern europe
is real and present
more so than for a long time a lot has
been said about the background and all
the links yes
russia is responsible for this
escalation therefore
our european decisiveness
um
when it comes to calling on russia to
withdraw its troops our most important
objective i think that
this has been underlined
is to avoid war dear dialogue and
de-escalation is the most important goal
we want peace throughout europe
people in ukraine
rightly want to have a life in peace but
also people in russia
want to live in democracy
and
want to
be rid of this military risk all actors
must
get out of this spiral of violence
we want dialogue and diplomacy but we
must all prepare for
prepared for sanctioned sanctions if
this situation deteriorates
thank you
mr shieder next speaker is frederic
reese
thank you very much madam president
vladimir putin is apparently suffering
both cold and warm we thought that we
were going to have an invasion this
morning it seems that it's the opposite
now and we've heard that there's been a
partial withdrawal of troops i think we
need to cautiously
look to this and hope for this
de-escalation now we know that putin is
placing the
timing and the tempo on all of this for
weeks i just have one minute so i'm have
to move uh very quickly through this so
the european union must
be resolute in the name of all and set
its package of sanctions and advance on
that comment defense we must also first
and foremost show the unwavering
solidarity to the ukrainian people that
is paying a very high price for its
freedom i remember very well mister high
representative as if it were yesterday
uh
victor eugenko was here in the hammer
cycle and there was
it was orange across the hemicycle here
you were at the president of the
european parliament at that time it was
in 2005 and i'd like to just quote him
the borders of
europe and freedom go all the way to
kiev now that was 18 years ago that uh
europe was uh feeling all of this and i
am concluding president
we must
keep in mind that it is our dna our
peace that is at stake here thank you
thank
you very much
next speaker jacob de lunde
do you have the floor
taxmaker
thank you very much madam president
regardless of
how this current situation ukraine will
end we have to deal with russian
aggression and take it seriously the
fact that russia is using the threat of
violence as a diplomatic
tool is completely unacceptable
regardless of how
to what extent they actually implement
that threat
russia is undermining international
law and the european security order
even if this threat is now
aimed at ukraine and that's being used
for leverage it is a tool that will be
used by russia against all of russia's
enemies
putin's always tried to split the eu it
often has the opposite effect in fact it
brings eu countries closer together and
creates unity in terms of security
policy
and that
is the way to go to counter
putin's claim for power european
solidarity with the ukrainian people and
their right to self determination and
their resolve is also the path forward
for europe common sanctions against
russia
and measures to support ukraine will be
decisive
i reiterate
a threat of violence is a serious
violation of the
world order regardless of the extent to
which that threat is actually carried
out if your neighbor comes over to you
and waves a pistol at you and threatens
you that is a crime regardless if that
pistol is actually shot or not thank you
i do not see philip deman
in the hemi cycle he is not
present
therefore i give the floor to angel
zambaski
thank you madam chair
dear colleagues allow me to quote
no treaty
with russia
is worth the paper that it's written
on
don't expect to have any benefits from
dealing with russia and
that's why
it's worth it to play with the russians
only honestly but
or another
or not play at all
i will give you a homework to find out
who this quote is from
in budapest there was a treaty
for
the nuclear weapons
at that time ukraine was the third
country
and uh russia was a
side to this treaty why do things
unfold this way because european
leadership is not skilled enough is not
intelligent enough and european
leaders would go separately and they
don't know how to develop a unified
position some of them talk about energy
independence the others are
building pipelines this is not going to
happen my dear colleagues
and i'm saying this with all the gravity
that this entails what we need to know
is mr burrell mr burrell you're talking
about
unity what unity mr burrell each and
every
european leader is going separately
some people are saying here
quietly
uh just to be part of the speaker's list
ukraine needs serious partnership
serious support economy not just empty
words not just
declarations and games
thank you
thank you mr jambosky next speaker is
emmanuel morale
we all want to prevent things from
getting worse
we want to
stop this
surge forwards which is going to
endanger european security we know that
even a limited attack
versus or against ukraine would justify
a very strong reaction on the part of
europe we should all agree to say that
among all the superpowers who are just
putting oil on the fire there isn't just
russia but of course that's a difficult
a point to make so we have to act to
avoid this disaster we don't want
ukraine to be destabilized or endangered
which means that we have to implement
the minsk agreements as france and
germany have been asking for
in the normandy format uh context but
unfortunately we have to say that for
the time being ukraine is not a member
of um
nato we can see that this could lead to
war and to ignore that by simply just
disregarding the arguments of russia
would not be a very responsible attitude
could i reiterate the fact that contrary
to the united states
russia is
going to remain on the european
continent and as chancellor schultz was
saying and president macron there's no
european security if there's no russian
security thank you
thank you mr morrell
and the next speaker is esteban gonzalez
for years we have tried to avoid any
kind of conflict with moscow but we
can't anymore
this is not the time for speculations or
cheap political talk
putin has made his intentions clear to
ukraine to europe and to the world
and says that diplomatic options are
still on the table but his troops are
prepared for the invasion of an
independent nation
negotiating with tanks with a gun on our
heads it's not negotiating it is black
mailing
make no mistake the target is ukraine
but we the european union we are the
goal
the threat is there it is now and it is
a real one the only question that we
have to answer is what are we going to
do about it do we stand down are we
going to be prisoners of a dictator or
do we unite put our political difference
aside and stand together against this
act of aggression
rather than being afraid let's hold our
heads high and make him understand he
will never divide us
last i don't want to forget that
yesterday a new trial began against
alexei navalny please remember that
today more than ever navalny represents
russia's hope
let's not condemn russia to suffer a
dictatorship forever
thank you mr gonzalez
the next speaker is isabel santos
or sinai
thank you very much
the signs of tension between russia and
ukraine
are
quite palpable
but we shouldn't allow ourselves to be
led to a conclusion
that we don't have any time left
to
deal with
these threats and our future our
security should not be defined by moscow
and washington we need to have it in our
own hands
nothing
has been lost yet when it comes to
diplomacy you can
only build peace however if you're
prepared to
show solidarity in responding to the
threat of war
in rhetorical terms we have to keep
within our limits
we
should
remain calm
the values set out in the helsinki final
act are clear
and they cannot be ignored
thank you miss santos the next speaker
is orma spite
for years russia has been keeping their
military in ukraine georgia and moldova
against the will of the governments of
those countries
thereby impeding the normal development
of these countries
also in the current situation where
russia has surrounded ukraine with its
military carries a purpose that ukraine
itself should not be able to decide on
its future
russia's goal is to get ukraine into its
sphere of influence
it wants ukraine to give up its path
towards the eu and nato
so far ukraine has managed to endure
despite the huge pressure
democratic western countries should not
make things more difficult for ukraine
this means that we must remain with the
ukrainians by supporting them every way
we can
it means also physical presence in
ukraine
above all we must maintain a strong and
visible diplomatic presence in ukraine
the continuous and high-level presence
of democracies in kiev and in other
parts of ukraine is of essence
especially these days thank you
[Applause]
bye thank you mr
bite the next speaker is grace
o'sullivan who's speaking from dublin
you have the floor
ukraine
a word ironically originating from the
slavic word for borderland
as tensions rise along its borders with
russia activities close to ukraine's
border with belarus are an ominous
reminder we are all of us citizens of a
world where the threat of nuclear knows
no borders
footage aired last week showing the
chilling site of ukrainian military
undertaking ammunition training in
pripyat and now abandoned city in
ukraine once home to workers of the
chernobyl nuclear plant just one
kilometer from the border with belarus
troops crept around empty apartments an
abandoned library a long quiet school
playground all in sight of chernobyl
scene of the world's worst nuclear
accident where today huge tanks store
radioactive waste the in the aftermath
of that ongoing tragedy there is no safe
way to stay store nuclear waste and
disturbing those dumps could have
catastrophic impacts on humankind and
the environment that crosses multiple
borders with the message when it's too
late that peace must always be the
ultimate goal
thank you mr sullivan
the next speaker is is this love cresson
devski you have the floor
about itself thank you
will they enter or will they not
enter
we asked the question in
1981 and 1956 in poland
when they entered in 1920 and 1940 they
murdered us
and stuffled
uh
stifled uh freedom
this time they
didn't
enter
but
for how long
unfortunately the union has ignored
the threat from russia
irrespective of what happened in
georgia and elsewhere
and the germans
under angela merkel a great european
invested in
nordstrom too
well now
germany france and the union
base
its policy on
the real
knowledge about russian
thank you very much
mr krasnodsky and the next speaker is
paulo ranchell
dear colleagues
it should be pointed out that the groups
which really defend the
self-determination and the sovereignty
of
states are those
who
um are the the uh
ones which should be defending ukraine
at the moment but just look at the
situation in donbass look at crimea
there's also a tension in transnistra in
georgia
in the european union
and
nato cannot fail nor can the united
states nor canada we cannot
forget about the population the
population should be free free of
corruption it should be a country which
should be able to enjoy a market economy
russia must understand that it cannot
impose or dispose of the will of a
sovereign and free uh people such as the
ukrainians so it is fundamental that uh
nato from vineyards to vancouver
from town to san francisco we should all
defend the freedom of peoples and
european uh people in particular
uh
stronger people do what they
want and the weaker
the weaker have to submit but ukraine
and europe are not weak and we are
strong because we're united against
dictators
clever ukraine
thank you mr angelum the next speaker is
rafael glucksman
colleagues
the end of 2013 a philosophy student was
one of the first to go down to the
streets with a european flag in her
hands to
launch the
revolution she was 25 years old andrea i
saw her in 2014
with
uh trying to face off the bullets of
snipers wanting to be free aspiring to
join the family of european democracies
this is the only crime that elena
drangie committed and the only crime of
the ukrainian people this is why crimea
was annexed and the donbass occupied
this is why 130 000 russian soldiers are
currently amassed on the borders and
threatening to turn our
continent to war because the european
nation wants to live freely in europe
we often fight of among ourselves among
democracies but look at the
ukrainian youth and look at the
understanding the value of this union
that we are gradually trying to build
today it is in kiev that you can best
understand what it means to be european
[Applause]
thank you mr glooksman
the next speaker is vice president
thank you very much
colleagues
nobody knows today how the current
crisis will end up but what we know for
sure is that it will determine the
future of our whole continent
if it becomes a norm again in europe
that strong states can do
whatever they wish that they can stamp
out the weaker smaller countries and
then decide on their destiny
take away the freedom sovereignty then
we all have a problem especially the
small countries on the eastern border of
the eu
as a politician from slovakia therefore
i consider it crucial for the eu to be
united and to act resolutely
in dialogue with moscow we need to show
political and financial support to
ukraine and also prepare strong
retaliatory sanctions we will not defend
only ukraine but also a higher principle
and that is that even smaller states
have a right to respect sovereignty and
security thanks to the eu we no longer
live in a jungle today where the strong
can do anything they want and the weaker
ones have to endure everything
if we leave ukraine left their devices
today we will end up in the jungle again
thank you
thank you very much
mr cenica the next speaker is
russia
has been proceeding on a road where they
seek power
by aggressive foreign policy russia have
not has not been able to increase its
citizens well-being or improve the
economy this power policy
is unpredictable it is a result of
weakness
russia threatens the stability
in europe and in ukraine but no other
country threatens russia
the
russia has itself invaded
crimea we have to make it clear to to
the russians that they cannot go on on
this road they have to support uh
or respect the sovereignty of other
countries we cannot
only just react we also have to have a
new direction in security we cannot just
respond to letters we have to take
initiative ourselves otherwise russia
will
continue the divide and rule policy and
we cannot
accept this minister
thank you very much mr ninist
the next speaker is charlie weimers
thank you very much madam president
is the eu going to send
tanks or they going to send blankets to
ukraine
weapons or millions of euros that could
just disappear the eu commission
should not be
spending more than they have and use
that budgetary approach
i would vote against any budgetary
support to any areas that are not well
administered either within or out with
the eu
another 12 billion of
eu money is going to ukraine and it can
be
it can disappear quite simply because it
is not earmarked and can be used for
whatever
means possible
surely the alarm bell should be ringing
here there should be military support
peace support and hit russia hard with
sanctions if they invade my own country
sweden is providing defense material
but the social democrats are against
that
the way of dealing with taxpayers money
and a false degree of solidarity with
the ukrainian people's what's happening
brits was
sending money to
sorry brits was sending
military support to ukraine but the
germans weren't yeah
thank you mr weimers the next speaker is
andre alichke
[Music]
shaun overview
ladies and gentlemen this debate is not
only about
ukraine's defense it is a debate about
our future the defense of europe
including my
country poland because what is putin
afraid of
he is afraid of a good example
that
comes from our
member states that
he is afraid that the ukrainians might
might
choose democracy
civic rights and fast development
and defense guaranteed by
nato
our duty
in
strasbourg and brussels is to tell putin
clearly
that ukraine has the right to choose its
future
uh
in
europe
and we must help
ukrainians solidarity with ukraine
in our interest in the interests of our
security and future
putin is afraid of all that because he's
afraid
uh that this a good example might
uh undermine
his position in russia
uh
democratic forces in russia are growing
in strength therefore
we need to remember about the democrats
in russia
free alexander navalny it's our duty
[Applause]
thank you mr alex kim
the next speaker is dietmar custer you
have the floor
that's this takes test yet
the most important thing now is to
maintain peace in europe
yesterday important steps were taken
and announced to achieve the escalation
the german
chancellor olaf schultz contributed to
this to make sure that
he rejected the delivery of weapons to
ukraine and kept the channels of
communication with russia open yes the
buildup of russian troops on the border
constitutes a threat and has led to this
tense situation i hope that moscow will
follow through on its promises to
withdraw
but we need to have an important
strategic autonomous security setup in
europe and to do that we have to take
russia seriously
without splitting it
and if russia feels threatened by nato
expansion we need to talk about it we
need to negotiate that
we have to have a security conference in
europe to deal with this security in
europe cannot exist
without russia
and that is the cost of the peace order
of peace in europe
thank you mr custer
the next speaker is elaine kuchuk
thank you madam president
dear colleagues
ukraine is europe
and ukrainian security
is a european security
mr burrell
unity among member states is the most
important for us
but we cannot have unity if we have
urban going and negotiating along with
putin
common action within nato and full
support
to ukrainian's independence territorial
integrity and strategic strategic
choices of the country
should be supported by by us
this is the only way to answer
to the unprecedented military aggression
that countries facing recently by the
russian federation
at the same time we need to continue
providing political support economic
health and assistance
to ukraine equating in defense and
security-related areas and to develop a
long-term strategy
this requires europe to formulate a
geopolitical answer because this crisis
also is a lesson for us and it could
dramatically change the way europeans
think about their own security
[Applause]
thank you mr gutechuk
i will now give the floor to reinhardt
boutique offer who is speaking from
berlin you have the floor
president colleagues
the fact that we europeans must be
showing solidarity with
ukraine has been rightly emphasized by
most speakers only the extremists from
the right and left make themselves
instruments of russian neo-imperialism
the rejection of a new intervention in
ukraine is not enough
you putin is also wanting to revise the
stability order in europe so our
response must cover all aspects of this
policy and counter it
russian recognition of the so-called
people's republics in the donbas must be
followed by tough sanctions
we should not allow
western greed to be exploited for by
putin so we should stop nordstrom 2 and
we should finally take a tough stance on
russian corruption and money laundering
in the eu
[Music]
like a
thank you colleague beautyconfirm
the next speaker is riho terras
madam vice president colleagues
there is no need to remind you the
severity of the ongoing crisis
putin's russia is working according to
the plan a strategic plan that has no
less a goal than challenging the west
and changing europe's europe's security
architecture
building up military presence and
tighten the news around the ukraine day
by day is not just a military drill
it is russia getting ready to attack one
of its neighbors
the war in ukraine has been ongoing
already for 80 years the strategic end
state putin has in mind has not been
delivered yet
ukraine has not collapsed and there is
no puppet regime in kiev to follow the
masters orders
putin's attempt to correct this mistake
he made can take place
any moment
don't let yourself be deceived by the
dislocation of troops
moving units back and forth is what you
do when you prepare for attack
russia is not de-escalating
they are escalating by adding pressure
with cyber attacks
the west should not leave ukraine
diplomats and media
should stay in place politicians should
visit ukraine daily
this is what ukraine needs now in
addition to material support from the
friends and partners
and last
but not least
eu must reaffirm strongly and openly
that ukraine has the perspective to join
the union one day
ukraine
thank you mr
terrace the next speaker is dice
wrighton
thank you madam president commission mr
high representative
yesterday we debated the cfsp and the c
sdp here and and i command you mr high
representative for your tireless efforts
in trying to bring about unity and with
success
but i expect more from the council peer
pressuring member states deliberately
jeopardizing this very unity for
internal political reasons or with
misconceptions of history
we must stand four square behind the
free and independent people of ukraine
true diplomacy through the provision of
defensive aid and through hard cash
because this is also about us about our
values about upholding international law
and it must be crystal clear ahead
of any further aggression ahead of any
further aggression how high the price
will be
freezing assets stop freedom of movement
for everyone related to the regime
banning russia from swift and halt
nordstream ii
my message to the russian people who are
not our enemy do not let mr putin drag
you into a senseless war and to the
people of ukraine long live democratic
ukraine thank you
[Applause]
you have the floor
college dear colleagues i would like to
join those of us who supported us
showing solidarity to ukraine and its
people
against uh putin but putin has always
been there he has already been testing
for years our
capacity to intervene
it has done that for years it has shown
support for dictators like bashar
al-assad what are we ready to do
i think that it's high time we actually
had a common security policy we already
accepted a qualified majority in the
decision making process i believe that
we should decouple ourselves for our
strategic dependencies that can be used
against us energy natural resources uh
strategic
and advanced technologies especially
when our dependencies are
on
undemocratic states we should have
concrete resources and concrete
engagement in the region of the black
sea which is which is a strategic region
for us when it comes to energy and
security thank you
keith
the next speaker is munir satori
we have to try to deter
a russia from a bloody war
were
faced with a nationalist somebody who's
prepared to sacrifice human life and we
cannot give in at all
now i
condemn those who are complacent and who
turn a blind eye to uh the violation on
the part of russia of human rights this
is such an important moment for ukraine
and the ukrainians but it's also
important for the security of the
european union and i expect member
states to be exemplary in their
consistence they must all be in favor of
sanctions they must say out loud that
operations such as north stream 2 will
be suspended immediately if russia
takes to weapons a stronger and more
united europe is the answer to this
crisis the expansion
of
nato which is too polarizing is not able
to solve this crisis thank you
thank you colleague satori
the next speaker is antonio and lopez's
stories who is speaking from madrid
thank you president and welcome to vice
president xines we should be clear that
this is a fight for the survival of our
way of life our democracy that's what is
at stake
putin's objective like the objective as
many other dictators and apprentice
dictatorships is not to have democracy
extend to their country for that they
use all possible weapons
threats to ukrainian territory and not
just a warning
based on the alliance of security which
we are and our commitments to nato above
everything we should defend our
democratic values not just in ukraine
but also in belarus in venezuela and in
russia itself supporting those who fight
for democracy such as alexei navalny
my friends on the left say that they
know very well that putin's russia is
not the soviet system people long for
maduro is not a socialist and the
chinese communist party is not communist
these are corrupt regimes full of
oligarchs who defend their economic
interests and they are impermeable to
democracy
under this initial premise the european
union should live up to the
circumstances and refor respond firmly
to what is happening in ukraine we
should practice the values we talk about
so much we should forget about the hope
of global
if we forget about this hope for
democracy there was a hope in the 90s
now we're into a new cold war democracy
is turning into autocracies we cannot
drop our guard and especially we must
focus on the economy which is our most
powerful tool we must have clear
sanctions prepared and directed to deal
with this kind of threat to our
democratic system thank you
and the next speaker is evin inside
the
befina
we are in the worst security situation
that we've seen for several decades
russian troops
tanks and missiles have encircled
ukraine and that country needs our help
the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine is important for us
for europe
whether our
people our children and our
right to decide to act under the rule of
law
we have to make sure
that we are not allowing
russia
to
dictate
because the threats to ukraine are
threats to the whole of europe and the
rest of the world
to have sustainable peace and security
we have to make sure that all parts of
the population are brought on board
my question to the high representative
and vice president then is how do we
ensure that we live up to our
commitments to include young people and
women in the peace processes pursuant
to 1325 and other un security council
regulation because all i've seen to date
is men men and more men
[Music]
thank you miss
[Music]
the next speaker is jose ramon bowser
you have the floor
thank you president
we still don't know for sure what will
happen in ukraine over the coming hours
but one thing is clear and that is that
europeans
have now been thinking for 30 years that
war in europe was impossible and we've
woken up from that unfortunately the
possibility is very real
and
it's not just
ukraine and nato that is at stake it's
also about the eu and the values that we
represent principles that are also
shared by our partners in ukraine and
our north american allies
along those lines these values that
putin counters
that he has declared war on for many
years also have enemies within the eu
itself yesterday the communist members
in podemos who were part of the spanish
government decided to vote against the
economic support that europe wants to
give to ukraine
communism is still being supported by
some parties in spain but
then bringing totalitarianism to europe
that is complicity with putin at a time
when democracy really needs support and
finally let me also say to mr burrell
that for people like putin you have to
face up to them i think this is what you
will want to do and you'll always have a
standing by you thank you
i could not imagine up to today's that
the slogan nazi slogan
nazi collaborator stephan bandera will
be pronounced from this tribune for many
times and they heard in the hemi cycle
we are living in the time of information
wars and one of the instruments is of
course slogan
one of the instruments is disinformation
and the example we are giving now having
just this
title of the debate russia's military
threat against ukraine
it is not proved it was repeated that he
today even mentioned that ukrainian
diplomats are denying elsewhere in the
european union this because it's
damaging ukraine
i will speak about facts facts
registered by the united nations oec
other bodies
these are
key children killed in donbass
during this eight years
152
children
were killed and
146
injured
the latest case is the case of slavic
dmitry
the boy four years boy killed by
drawn
on
colleague and our rules prevented yes
excuse me
i
obliged to tell you that according to
the rules
this is not allowed i'm very sorry so
your time is out
and his parents asked to tell
stop killing stop killing donbass
children
you have to do this outside uh the
plenary thank you guys
so the next speaker is
come
commissioner
kremlin wants to negotiate with nato and
the us
to put in place a new security
architecture
by establishing the ussr
zones areas of influence shows that
russia
negates the right to severity of
independent states to to decide on their
own alliances and their own security
the long
list
of
compromises that we've shown
russia for business for from some eu
companies but also for the supply of gas
at preferential prices have given money
to this army this army that now
threatens the peace of european
countries
so this business as usual that we all
love
is now hampering the security of ukraine
of the baltic countries of poland of
romania and bulgaria
these days the us and the uk reacted
swiftly
um
giving military help to ukraine and the
eastern flank
nato is the only
shield for secure security that we have
at least for now
security solutions in europe are
speeding up
the independence the process of
energetic independence
from russia
uh discouraging russia military in
military terms and putting an end to
political compromises in favor of russia
thank you very much
thank you colleague
the next speaker is robert biedron you
have the floor
we are the second largest democracy in
the world it is a great responsibility
uh to support democracy across the world
as well as peace across the world
it is another yet another debate
that shows that peace is not cannot be
guaranteed it is another lesson that we
could have
prepared better
it is another crisis
provoked
by russia because russia wants ukrainian
belarus and those two countries want
freedom
and therefore
we need to provide tangible support
and we
need to have a conference on the future
of belarus we need support for ukraine
and we in particular need a
plan for both belarus and ukraine
we also
have to
do away with unanimity in foreign
policy
we have 27
ministers of foreign affairs long live
free and democratic ukraine
thank you mr
piedron
next speaker is vice president dieter
you have the floor
thank you madam president
ukraine is an independent and sovereign
state a free european nation that should
decide its future itself
so our message today to our friends in
ukraine is that europe is ready
to help
from arms to funds it must be clear who
are the true friends of a free ukraine
and that the europeans doors are open
i still hope in a diplomatic solution
however if russia acts
we as europe must be ready to respond
these sanctions must hit hard
not only the economic ones but also the
oligarchs and corrupt officials in
russia
but more than anything we must show our
solidarity with ukraine
ukraine needs strong allies in these
difficult times
slava ukrainian
thank you colleague charanzova the next
speaker is thomas weitz you have the
floor
thank you president commissioner
are we aware that
tens of billions of euros
are being spent by us
indirectly and supporting
putin's regime and co-financing the
build-up of troops on the border with
ukraine
paying for gas isn't just a climate
issue it's a security issue i think we
should have done our homework
and there needs to be re replacements
found for provision of gas to europe we
need to leave gas behind not just for
climate policy reasons but for security
concern reasons as well and that auburn
is now using russian money russian
technology
having a nuclear power station and built
on the fault line by the way is not just
a climate problem it's a security
problem
the interests of europe and the
interests of hungarians
are being submitted and sold to the
regime of putin and last but not least
if you think that through taxonomy
you're allowing gas to come in as a
green
open for green investments from the
private sector you really haven't
understood the serious nature of the
situation
[Music]
thank you colleague rights
the next speaker is christoph hansen you
have the floor
thank you madam president the executive
vice president the situation on the us
eastern borders especially at the
ukrainian border is far from being
resolved
let's not get fooled by the potemkin
retreat of his troops that putin is or
is not staging while we are speaking
let's not be fooled while the online
networks of
ukraine's defense ministry and two banks
are knocked out by cyber attacks this is
not a coincidence and my colleague
rioters has highlighted this putin
couldn't care less about an economic
crash in his country when the situation
of instability allows him to maintain
and extend his power grab elsewhere on
our side we need to support
ukrainians wherever we can they are more
therefore more than welcome the macro
financial assistance we granted this
week to ukraine but the current crisis
also cruelly highlights once again our
weakness when it comes to speak with one
single voice in foreign policy did macro
schools or better convey the same
message to putin i strongly doubt this
so when do we get once and for all writ
of unity unanimity in foreign policy
the executive by vice president how are
you planning to speed up the development
of pasco to better be prepared to the
next crisis that will inescapably come
down the road the success of these
projects will be the precondition to be
taken serious on the international stage
putin is trying to divide the west to
better reign no doubt about that but
this should be should be our chance and
our encouragement to unite putin's worst
case scenario is a united west let's not
get fooled let's stick together
hansen
thank you colleague hanson
i do not see
elizabeth gualamini in the hemi cycle
therefore i give the floor to clemen
grosser
you have the floor
ladies and gentlemen the crisis at the
ukrainian-russian border demonstrates
that we are living in an unpredictable
world where great powers ruthlessly
compete with each other and where the
use of force is sadly becoming a reality
the current crisis is however not
determining only ukraine's future but is
also representing a battlefield of
opinions as to the future of the
european security infrastructure this
infrastructure has been providing a
relative peace and stability in europe
for the past 30 years its foundations
can be found in a demanding negotiations
during the cold war period we have to
realize that we are facing tectonic
movements in the european security
infrastructures
but these movements are a process that
has been going on for some time now and
shall continue unfortunately it will
most likely go on in a series of crisis
that we have been and will be seeing in
the broader european area it will be of
decisive importance for the us nato and
the eu to realize that this process
requires us to be united and
unequivocally committed to the
fundamental democratic values we will
have to be patient decisive tenacious
and very wise
we will be facing an extremely demanding
geopolitical game in which we will
prevail not only by being diplomatically
dexterous and militarily decisive but
also clearly committed to democracy
because of these reasons the eu must
strengthen its autonomy on not only the
area of military but energy
thank you colleague grozel
the next speaker is massimiliano salini
you have the floor grazia president
thank you president
now the good news
is that there is a partial withdrawal of
the russian armed forces from the
ukrainian border
but this news
was preceded indeed by a statement by
president zielenski
and the german chancellor mr schultz
prior to that
and those statements are not very
reassuring because
zielinski basically says that that
ukrainian membership of nato is only a
dream and chancellor schultz says that
ukrainian
entry into nato is not on the political
agenda
now we can't consider this to be a
victory
we can't lower our guard
we can't say that poor declare that
we're satisfied
the
all the letters sent by russia to uh
nato countries and we replied with a
single reply as a as the eu is excellent
news
but in that single letter
speaking one voice there should be a
single position nobody depended
nobody uh obliged us to depend on
russian gas and yet we did or to a very
large extent we did
and then there were very complex
situations uh in africa for instance
where we withdrew
leaving room for the russians so there's
no single policy behind that letter no a
single economic strategy and that is
what we need thank you
sally thank you
mr
salini the next speaker is carmen
abraham
voy nunca
you do not understand russia
the officials in moscow accuse us and
they're right how can we with our values
understand
a dictatorship with the imperialistic
nostalgias
on the other hand
it is difficult to understand
why when we clearly understand putin's
intentions like bringing troops
uh so close to our borders the european
union is not able to
speak
firmly and to decide on repercussions to
be silent to tolerate this blackmail or
to believe that putin might become
an apostle for peace is a mistake
regardless of the end of this crisis if
the eu wants to be a powerful and
credible world actor
europe needs to act firmly because putin
will never keep up
just interfering with our lives
but if we are correct in business and if
we are swift to intervene intervene that
uh we then we will do everything right
thank you
thank you colleague abraham
and the next speaker is catalin j you
have the floor
thank you hi representative dear
colleagues
let's pause for a moment and let the
dark truth sink in
for the first time in decades there is a
very real chance that there will be war
in europe
as we debate in this very house there
are still russian troops staring down
ukraine on the eu's eastern
neighborhood we all read the news that
they might attack today many of us in
this chamber come from countries
bordering ukraine
this is real this would be our war we
might not be fighting it but we will
feel the consequences
and we should feel responsible for
preventing it and yes we are in the 24th
hour but europe still has not exhausted
all of its opportunities we need to
leave no doubt that a war will have
severe repercussions and this must
include suspending the north stream to
project or closing down europe's
financial system for russian
state-sponsored actors
and in the longer term we need to
rethink our ties with russia if putin is
capable of holding a continent on high
alert for months europe must have the
tools to do the same this is an
existential question before achieving
this all the commission's talks about
the geopolitical commission remains
unfortunately empty
thank you colleague
the next speaker is ludek niedermayer
you have the floor
thank you madam
commission president rightly said this
conflict is about democracy about the
values and about the freedom and she's
right but also in such a conflict
diplomacy play a very important role
it seems to me that it was rather clear
position of nato first stance of u.s
diplomacy and effort of some european
politicians that turn turn the situation
to to better
eu foreign policy didn't play sufficient
role i guess this is another wake-up
call for us we need such a foreign
policy that would work and that would be
recognized
european countries also should invest
more into military we cannot afford to
be again free rider of the nato
also we must be much better prepared for
conflicts with the countries that are
important supplier of energies like
russia not ex-ant evaluation not not
exposed evaluation but excellent
assessment of the risk and sufficient
guard how to protect our people and how
to protect our economy
we shouldn't fool ourselves despite of
ease of the pressure russia is still
sponsoring war in east ukraine millions
of ukrainians are suffering and we have
troubles to find the right way how to
help them and also protect our interests
at the same time i believe that politics
of mr putin is getting more aggressive
and less predictable
we again should not be naive
suffering of his country wouldn't change
his mind because it doesn't attach his
his well-being only very bold sanctions
can have an impact so the next time we
must be much more better prepared than
this time thank you
[Applause]
thank you colleague niedermeyer
the next speaker is leshek miller you
have the floor
madam president ladies and gentlemen
yesterday in moscow
chancellor schultz said that
war in europe is unthinkable for his
generation for my generation it is also
unthinkable and therefore we must do
everything to prevent
such war
uh the presidents of the council and the
commission said that so far
we have managed to de-escalate the
situation but russia still
maintains
forces
that can
uh
threaten
ukraine uh surrounding ukraine with uh
troops is a not peaceful
it is offensive
right now
it is uh
european
leaders
are talking with russian but the
institutions the european institutions
are not
taking part
we must
help ukraine with financial resources
and a plan for its membership
thank you colleague and miller
the next speaker is ghiber hofstadt you
have the floor thank you i'm asking
myself mr bottle what are you going to
take from here as a conclusion of this
debate
um
in my personal view i think there is an
enormous unity in this in this
parliament
besides some
people of the extreme left who are still
thinking that
the soviet union exists
and besides
a part of the extreme right financed by
by putin i think all the rest
has a huge unity
and i think that the conclusion of this
debate if i can give
an advice or a suggestion is that we
need a more robust
strategy of the european union it's true
you did your job and maybe more than is
possible with 27
ministers of foreign affairs
but the conclusion of this debate is we
need a more robust
stance i was on the
20th of february of maidan 2014
when in the morning 49 people were
killed by snipers and i've seen in the
eyes of these people how they
belong in fact to europe want to be in
the european union their future is there
not with putin even for those people who
speak russian in ukraine they don't want
that putin comes in
so i think we have to be more of us we
need to do more first of all maybe use
the
european peace facility to do a common
transfer of defensive weapons to them we
could do that we have the
uh the the the instrument to do that and
finally and then i i stopped miserable
because i know that you have a strong
instrument with you your hammer
that is that we need also a pro-russian
agenda because putin is not russia
and there is there an opposition
with navalny we need our food support
because in the end there will only be
stability in security in europe if there
is a democratic russia at our borders
[Applause]
college
now i
have to make a declaration we will now
move on to the first voting session of
today we will vote on the falls as
indicated on the agenda the voting
session will open
from 12 30 to 1 45 pm the voting method
will be
the same as during the previous voting
session all vote will be held by roll
call i declare the voting session open
you have until 1 45 pm to vote the
results of the votes will be announced
at 7 pm
and the discussion will now continue i
now give the floor
to francisco
jose milan you have the floor
thank you president
firstly i would like to send a message
of condolences and solidarity to the
families of the many fishermen who have
been affected by the tragic accident
yesterday and the galician vessel
ladies and gentlemen
for weeks now in europe we've been
facing a very serious unprecedented
situation in the face of the
accumulation of russian troops at the
ukraine border the european union must
maintain its posture of respecting
sovereignty and the territorial
integrity of the country
the kremlin is
following a policy based on zones of
influence ignoring the basic principles
of international law and the agreements
we've reached putin does not share our
values and principles an international
order based on standards multilateralism
and the rule of law the situation of
threat and bribery is unacceptable but
we need to continue to pursue the
diplomacy without making concessions on
key points recently it seems that there
is a partial withdrawal starting of
russian troops and some movement with
dialogue but it's early for optimism we
must maintain a united front in the face
of the challenge from putin the european
union including france and germany must
coordinate its response with the us and
nato to ensure that we maintain peace
respecting basic standards of
international law and the european peace
security thank you
milan
thank you colleague milan
the next speaker is robert heijon you
have the floor
dear colleagues
we need to show solidarity towards
ukraine towards ukrainian people
who have a right to decide on their
destiny the european union must to
continue supporting the ambitions of
ukraine to become part of the eu as soon
as it's prepared to fulfill all the
conditions as soon as we as the eu are
able and ready to accept them as a
member let's not create false
expectations then that it'll uh become
reality in the future for us the main
task is now to do everything we can to
prevent war and de-escalate
tension not to provoke hysteria
like some politicians and media are
doing predicting that the war should
start today apparently
the initiatives of germany and france
should be applauded when we
hear some politicians uh the probability
of war has diminished apparently
um
some troops have been moved
away from the border which might be a
positive single signal but we must
continue with diplomacy
we must continue creating security
architecture in europe
so that any country can feel secure
france slovakia lithuania but nobody
should be able
to increase their security at the
expense of somebody else
as long as russia doesn't feel secure in
europe unfortunately we will not be able
to feel secure either
many thanks colleague heisha
the next speaker is juliana
you have the floor
um high representative
it was only yesterday that we had a
debate on our common security and
defense policy
this morning we are talking about the
prime example of a threat to european
security the military tensions at our
eastern borders show once again the need
to develop a strong european strategic
sovereignty
we need to increase our common capacity
we need to develop a decisive and
assertive foreign policy i express my
solidarity with the people of ukraine
that live in uncertainty and prepare for
the worst
over the last weeks eu member states
have shown unity and close cooperation
with our transatlantic and nato partners
it is through this joint stance and
continued search for diplomatic way to
the escalation that we have managed to
keep the peace
we must remain a vigilant and we must
remain united thank you
thank you colleague zofco
the next speaker is brando benife you
have the floor
thank you president
a few years ago on one of those rare
occasions
where this
incredible animal
politics
there was
senator mattio salvini was a member of
parliament at the time and he came into
this house with putin on a t-shirt who
had been allegedly attacked by
stupid urophiles i wonder whether he
would consider
the head of his party marco zanni
to be one of those he explained that
putin's
regime
is such that
the ukrainians have to be
defended at all costs do you think that
people don't have any memory do you
think that they've forgotten about the
metropole hotel and all the
investigations about
russian funds to the uh league
what we really need is a firm stance
against russian attacks we need a new
european attitude which involves
everybody this is the future for europe
if we want to keep our place in history
thank you
uh
thank you colleague benny fame
and if you speak that fast the
interpreters have a lot of trouble
doing their job i ask you to speak
slightly slower so the message passes
better
the next speaker is vladimir bielczyk
you have the floor
colleagues
today
we have to be united vis-a-vis the
russian aggression political
institutions have to express their
support for ukraine what are the steps
that we can take
we can send military
help to ukraine as our allies have
already done we have to support
potentially hard sanctions
such as disconnecting russia from swift
we can help them economically because in
this situation it is disadvantageous for
ukraine to
borrow money and the investors are not
willing to lend it anyway we can
help ukraine financially and i support
the
initiative of the commission
we also
have to help them
by means of unitarian aid there has been
a war going on for several years and
civilians have been suffering especially
in these winter months and we have to
also suffer
we have to fight against uh
disinformation mr borel for european
diplomats it's important to stay in kiev
so that we
defend our values thank you
thank you colleague bill chick
the next speaker is carsten lucca
for president
president
colleagues
we still have a complex situation and in
the midst of that i stand behind
european solidarity with ukraine we must
continue to keep it as our utmost
priority that we reduce the risk of war
in europe in the short and medium term
and it's only possible to do that
through diplomatic means but what do the
citizens of this continent want in the
long term they want peace a lasting
comprehensive peace on the continent and
above all a peace order which is
appropriate for the 21st century over
recent days and weeks i've heard a lot
about red lines and maximalist demands
but at the end of the day olaf schultz
said yesterday that we all need to take
a step backwards and i think everybody
has to move and i think one of the
advantages of a crisis is that it can
give us an opportunity to focus and
perhaps
now we have a window of opportunity to
make a decisive courageous step in that
direction
and if
we have gone 30 years backwards in our
relations now is the time that we should
look forward to the next 30 years of our
relationship thank you
yeah thank you colleague
the next speaker is lucas fordlas you
have the floor
madam president commissioner mr burrell
it's important that we speak with one
voice in europe and you said that
before mr burrell but that doesn't
always happen
if europe had been speaking with one
voice
then i think we would have carried more
clout when it came to cyprus for example
the threats to greece armenia etc often
we talk about things but don't act in
ukraine the issue is also about the
security of europe the situation is that
that security is at risk today
this is european european territory
and
others are trying to take it into their
sphere of influence
and that is quite considerable
the french presidency in office said
that the ukraine issue will only be
solved diplomatically any use of
violence will be condemned as a european
citizen as a cypriot
of course
we need to keep to
public international law and that should
be the case in ukraine as well
thank you colleague fordlas the next
speaker is elon de basto you have the
floor
thank you
thank you very much madam president for
me it's absolutely clear that every
people has the right to decide on their
own future
it's a principle that is non-negotiable
it needs to be made clear that this
conflict finds its origins in the
ambitions for power in russia that's
holding people in the grip of steel it's
not just a question of threatening the
integrity of ukrainian territory but
also the choice of the people of ukraine
to decide on their future and also
threatens the stability that's
characterized our current situation
we have to make sure this aggression
is allowed to carry on without any
consequences madam president i'm very
pleased that today we are standing
shoulder to shoulder today in the union
the
speech from the president of the
commission was very clear i welcome it
and
makes it very clear what the situation
is and i think is proportionate with the
threat that we're facing
we've chosen our path now we are going
to keep
dialogue open and diplomacy open it's
now up to putin and russia to mo to make
sure that he will also stand on the
right side of history
the next speaker is sean kelly you have
the floor
we stand over another potential deadly
crisis orchestrated by vladimir putin
but whether an invasion happens or not
he's threatened war and backed up that
press with the deployment of 150 000
troops close to ukraine and in a
neighboring country belarus
the military build up around ukraine has
not been seen since the cold war
nevertheless there is still room for
diplomatic resolution and i sincerely
hope this is the path chosen by mr putin
however
this is a keen reminder that russia
cannot be a trusted partner for the eu
and this should include how we get our
energy
president von deline is right it is in
europe's strategic interest to diversify
our gas sources to reduce our dependence
on russia
our future lies in homegrown renewables
but until we fully transition lng can
provide an avenue away from russia
with terminals future approved to handle
green energy in this regard i would ask
minister ayman ryan in ireland to take
stock of this debate here today
thank you colleague kelly i will now
give the floor to alfred sant who's
speaking from valletta to invade the
ukraine as of now it would be a gross
mistake and greatly damage russia's
standing and interests
acknowledging this does not imply that
the current impasse is solely russia's
responsibility
indeed western powers from witting the
eu and nato and from outside
consistently believed they had the upper
hand in any long-term face-off with
russia
they ignored russia's legitimate
concerns about its security
intervened in its economy and broke
their open-ended promises not to extend
their military reach in europe when this
helped promote regrettable
authoritarianism in russia's governance
they consolidated the face of further as
a result
the legitimate security and other
concerns of russia's neighbors became
constrained they now have to consider
their only protection as nato
should not the goal have been a european
diplomatic architecture allowing equally
for the security concerns of russia its
neighbours and western europe as a whole
french president the goal once called
for a europe united from the atlantic to
the euros
german chancellor willie brandt once
launched his host politik
they foresaw europe in which both russia
and the rest of europe occupy the
meaningful space
why has the vision been abandoned thank
you
thank you colleague sent i now give the
floor to vice president of marquaras
president ladies and gentlemen i turn to
the citizens of europe
our approach in the european parliament
is clear
we are
committed to the political project
overcoming the violent division of
europe and the cold war
putin wants to turn back the wheel of
history we defend our rights and our
values
both internally and also the sovereignty
of our neighbours putin
violates and ignores and is willing to
blackmail and turn to war our weapons
and instruments are diplomacy
sanctions
support for ukraine ukrainian
independence sovereignty
and decisiveness
and we have a common foreign and defense
policy
we condem
the intended recognition of luhansk and
donetsk because it would entail a
division of ukraine our sanctions are
clear
nordstrom 2 must be stopped
we must be
freezing assets
and
exclusion from swift and also no
deliveries of high-tech technologies
but at the same time president
we
ought not just to go back to the agenda
business as usual the kremlin is
occupied in the valley in prison
thank you colleague
i now give the floor to dominic ruiz de
veza
thank you president
and thank you to the higher
representative and vice president of the
commission joseph barrell
not only for the
information that he has passed to us but
also the line with which he has been
taken
taking on russia for more than a year
it is a firm and clear line always open
to dialogue but from a position which is
clearly without complexes and
in that context a lot has been said in
this debate about
how we have used this dual track of
dissuasion and dialogue and in view of
the most recent news perhaps it is
working although we can't be sure so i
won't
repeat or reiterate any more that's been
said on that what i would like to say is
how can we take opportunity this
opportunity to strengthen more the
process of european integration and
transatlantic cooperation
we have strengthened our unity in the
west in the face of this challenge so
let's take advantage of this to
act on the provisions of article 42 in
the treaty
setting up the common defense system and
also to strengthen our transatlantic
relations for example holding a summit
with the united states and why not we
could update adopt a new atlantic
charter
thank you very much
i now give the floor to elgin tomok
you have the floor
thank you madam president high
representative commissioner
dear colleagues i believe that the
debate we are having today is really uh
important and i'm telling you
this from the point of view of somebody
who
has had an interdiction to enter uh
russia from 2015.
i have this introduction from uh the
kremlin because uh
i have
continuously criticized putin putin's
policy
through which he managed to maintain
a military presence in transnistria
therefore in the republic of moldova for
30 years
i and my parents were born in a region
occupied by the ussr a region that
belonged to romania before the um
first world war i know these realities
because i lived them
today in uh ukraine we have a
half a million romanians living there
and i ask you
um
to do whatever you can together with our
allies to stop putin thank you
thank you very much colleague tomok
and the final intervention before the
high representative
yvonne stefanik here on the floor
between authoritarianism and democracy
kremlin is testing our unity
during last years kremlin invested a
huge amount of resources just to
destabilize our common project
our common project which brought peace
to europe and prosperity to our families
i'm sure that peaceful solution cannot
be reached through inaction
our position must be clear and strong
in case of any forced attack stronger
sanctions that will practically cut
aggressor from the developed world
should be our weapon
at the same time we have to show
friendly face to cranin indians i
welcome the 1.2 billion euro package and
i do hope we will see more ukrainians
also to study at the european
universities and to enter in the
european institutions we should continue
to empower the
eu ukraine cooperation at the economic
level by reducing burdens at our markets
for good services and labor today we
have to show our unity to the dictator
and we will not only win but we will
emerge from current situation even
stronger thank you
thank you very much colleague stephanie
and now i would like
to invite the high representative to
give his final intervention
thank you president
white exchanges today
intensity and extension of our exchanges
today
because it has been almost 100
interventions governing the full
spectrum the full political spectrum of
this house
shows
how important the situation is and
underlines
the gravity of the situation
and europe
is very much right
apart from the far right on the far left
it has been a remarkable unity among the
members of the parliament which
represents more or less
the same unity between member states
with neons certainly
but
with a strong unity
among us
and
the issue and gui has already said that
is that ukraine is not a military threat
to russia
but this is a
political threat because if ukraine
builds a vibrant democracy
and goes on to a prosperous economy
then it will be an example
and
in russia's putin
after 20 years of his government
the economics is in bad shape
and the system is more or more
autocratic or authoritarian
even today we can see that
the opposition politician navalny
inside the penal colony
is
starting another trial against him
regulatively without any possibility of
observation
so ukrainian
continues advancing on their reforms
building a democracy and building a
prosperous economy
this is something that russia has put in
can certainly not look with good eyes
but ukrainians has made certain lady a
choice
and i think that most of them they
prefer to live on the democracy rule of
law
and a free market economy
then look into what's happening in
russia
and this is the real issue
the real issue is how can we support
ukraine
on this path
to the democracy and economic
prosperity impossible to answer or even
to refer to all the questions that you
have been raising today
i just want to to answer in particular
heal the government when she was asking
me directly can ensure you that
has this unity
has not been jupitized by the initiative
taken by some member states
certainly
certainly
several members of the european union in
particular france
and in particular president macron but
also germany
have taken political initiatives to try
to encourage a peaceful settlement of
the crisis
but
all of these initiatives have been
conducted in coherence with the
positions of the union
and
in conditions of great transparency
we were informed before and after those
initiatives
and i think
that around
ukraine there is a climate of confidence
developing between member states
as regards this crisis
and i think that this is the best way to
respond to the russian aggression so
please be assured ladies and gentlemen
these initiatives have not been
taken just on an ad hoc basis they have
not weakened european unity on the
contrary they have enabled us to be more
active and
to take a greater role
in the diplomatic efforts which have
been taking place
some other members have been asking but
you have been discussing negotiating
with russia it has been any kind of
concessions certainly not first we
haven't been negotiating with russia so
if there is no negotiation there is no
concessions we have just
answering letters
in a very much united way and certainly
my political director
held with its russian counterpart in
january
talks about european
situation in general and they discuss
about the political situation around the
ukrainian crisis but i cannot consider
that negotiation so don't bother don't
be worried about possible concession
from one side or the other
many issues about the diversification of
energy supply but i think that to that
uh the president of the commission has
given a very complete answer on all the
work that she personally and my police
commissioners and myself we have been
doing with other suppliers of gas norway
algeria serbian
u.s
talking with also
countries in the pacific who can reroute
some supplies of gas
and this a lot of work
presents us the advantage of being ready
and able to face a crisis on the
university side
what i want to stress
is that in the face of the russian
military threat
we believe that still a diplomatic way
out of the crisis that russia has caused
is still possible
and this is our top priority
and that what we are investing
in
all our efforts
let me stress that
we still believe that the diplomatic out
of the crisis is possible
but in parallel
we have accelerated the work on
restrictive measures
that's why the treaty calls
what we use sanctions as the worst
scientists are not in the treaty just
restrict the measures
including sectoral financial and
individual sanctions that would be
adopted
in close coordination with like-minded
countries in europe and across the
atlantic in case of a military
aggression
be sure of that
and be sure also that
even if moscow deliberately
has been bypassing european security
discussions
because president putin profoundly
disagree with the values that we
european union practice and defend
and this is the real problem they
disagree with our values with our
way of living with european way of
living what what do we represent of
combination of political freedom
economic prosperity and social cohesion
and this is since the beginning of the
crisis why we have been expressing our
principal positions about the main
parameters
that have defined european security
architecture for the last 30 years from
now
but we have to think about
what
russia is looking for
what do what does russia want
on creating this crisis
and i think that
they have several objectives
the first one
is to return
at the heart of the world game
to be recognized as an equal player
with us with the u.s at a time when the
u.s is turning towards asia
to be again reconsidered as a global
player and i have to say that from this
point of view putin has got some success
because now everybody is talking with
him he has pledged the center of the
political game
the second
the second purpose
linked to the first
is also
intended to test the possibility of a
decoupling
between the united states and europe
particularly after the american
withdrawal from afghanistan
and in this respect
they should be quite disappointed
because our unity has been increased not
weakened
and finally
he seeks
to reconstitute
the former
soviet sphere
by raising the fears about nato
enlargement
and that's true
but the question of natural enlargement
plays an important role
under russian psychology
in this relation
to the west
but to try to reduce everything in this
crisis to the question of nato
enlargement
or to think that
once a possible guarantee of
ukraine's membership or non-membership
to nato could be obtained
to believe that this would solve
everything
and we will go back to normal
it's illusory it's illusory
simply
because when you look at what is
happening in belarus
which no one
has ever said
that belarus could join the european
union or nato
we are witnessing
a real russia stronghold on the country
sin lukashenko was in trouble
and playing for his survival
at the price of the integration
and even absorption into a greater
russia
so no
don't reduce that to the nato expansion
the big problem
is the fight between two different
political and economic systems what do
we represent our values and their values
our way of living
on their way of living
this is the real fight
it's not a fight between armies it's a
fight about ideas
which sometimes is much more important
until now
nothing is played
nothing is won
but
we have to keep vigilant
what we must avoid
basically
is a radiation
of the crimea scheme
where
we were quite surprised by the invasion
reacted
with sanctions
but nothing more
now
we must show that any invasion of
ukraine is in any form
whatever it takes in any form it takes
be it the national donbass
or
isolated
military incursion into the rest of
ukraine
would be prohibitedly expensive for
russia
for russia
and for its oligarchs
so the package of sanctions that we are
working that we have already ready to
implement
has to be strong
and credible
but at the same time
we must not close the door to a
discussion
even
when discussing we must apply the rules
of social
distancing
must therefore
combine firmness and determination
with a willingness to engage in a
dialogue as soon as russia agrees to
play the game of negotiation
and to move away from the logic of
ultimatum and military intimidation
that has been practicing for several
months now
mr lavrov has just declared that he is
ready to continue discussions
so let's do it
let's discuss seriously
but without lowering our guard
i hope this debate will have mark this
path
thank you to all
many thanks honorable high
representative for your intervention
and as you mentioned we have had a very
intensive and important discussion
we will continue the debates at 3 p.m
with the topical debate based on rule
162
the topic is one youth one europe i wish
you a nice lunch break
you